e
e e
we will get started and um what I wanted
to do just to kind of start us on the
right foot even though we're a little
bit short-handed but we can do it anyway
turn to page one in house bill one
please page
one see I can look over your shoulder
you got it okay all right so what you
can see on page one of house bill
one hey Johan
okay are we there y okay so this is um
the legislative branch and in particular
it's the
Senate and um if you look for 2024 they
actually spent
2,928 uh
1,863 but they are budgeted for these
two years of
3,548 th000 right so uh
roughly something over what is this
580,000
more is that
right a lot more
yeah what about us actually sorry it's
it's 600,000
more right 620,000 more and we're
level um yeah we'll we'll get to the
house oh the house curious what right so
the house well the house is is sort of
600,000 more but on a bigger number
right right right okay and maybe we'll
cut them later but I just thought kind
of as our first thing and and to try to
get
us heading on the right step that I
would propose a
$500,000 per year cut to this particular
page so there would still be 120 more
than they actually spend in
2024 do you have any yes represent of
eil thank you do you have any idea what
that is
for the additional that they have
here yes you can see it's in the
personal I just okay sorry I didn't
track back up I I'll admit I hadn't
studied this page right so it's it's
it's all
in well it's not kind of all but it's
it's mostly in
Personnel right representative Maguire
yes Melissa in order to make the cuts um
we need to know line items and where you
would like to cut
so although you say $500,000 we would
need to know if you want that as a
percentage for each class item or how
you want to divy that up well it's going
to be personnel and
benefits right so
um so I
guess we'd want the Personnel to be
level with this
right and then the benefits would would
kind of come along
one
one um this chair starts at the
beginning yeah and we could also I mean
there's also instate travel right that
could be
lower and out of state travel that could
be
low anyways um so I guess maybe we can
ask you to come up with plan that would
cut that would make it 500,000 lower
roughly does that
work yeah as long as you give us
Direction so if you're giving us
direction for those uh yeah so the lines
would be class 16
class uh 60 um class 70 and
right yeah
okay so we can we can spread that out
and then we'll have a spreadsheet for
you which will be part of keeping track
of hb1 and then when it's all um
allocated out then we can do a vote
right
um because it looks to me like the the
million is just copied from fiscal year
2025 authorized it's not the actual
employees that are there in the 1.8
million
right so I think this goes to a couple
of things we were emailing about with
the difference in cost you have the
employee raise factored into that you
have positions are very fluid so in the
sense that there could have been some
vacant positions in fiscal year 25 24
that are now filled in fiscal year 25 so
maybe at this point the Senate assumed
that they were at full capacity with
positions so they're funding now at the
level of what they have for 25 what we
don't know in these numbers is how much
is
unfunded um how much is unfunded vacant
positions and how much is filled
positions so that
500,000 could potentially be positions
let let me put it this way it that
column that says fisal year of 2025
adjusted authorized that was created two
years ago
correct no no so this is a point in time
that this I don't know the exact date I
could get that of when um the adjusted
authorized but that is a closer
reflection of a point in time of what 25
looked like and how they would close it
was not what was created if it was what
was created um two years ago it would
have been the budgeted number from two
years ago but instead this adjusted
authorized means any carry forwards from
24 of dollars that were unspent any
fiscal items that were approved any hb2
items that hit 25 but didn't hit 24 any
Appropriations um and what so this is
this is a more accurate thing of what
they think is going to end this year yes
with the current employees Etc correct
because it's a point in time the closest
point in time in the budget that they
actually had gotcha all right so so my
idea is not good I have a question yes
um
are these numbers all General funds or
is that all funds together these are all
General funds yeah okay the Senate is
all General
funds I see so you're
thinking all right so all right
fine I did I did have a Reason by the
way um because the the Senate every one
of them has
staff and in the old days when we had
joint committees chaired by a senator
their staff would would U provide
services for the committee but they have
since changed their um procedures so
that even when they're chairing a joint
committee they no longer provide staff
for that committee all right so they
don't need as much staff as they used
to so anyways all right we will skip
this and we will move on to retirement
was a good exercise well
yeah yes
welcome all
right so you are on
page5 or 154
155 here we
go
okay so I
I is there any kind of presentation you
want to give us because very briefly
because I I had I just wrote questions
based on what I'm seeing in the book
here so um yes we handed out um a
presentation
believe yeah but this is similar to what
we had before
right there are no there are budget
schedules in there and me just there are
some highlights which kind of May repeat
some of the things we said before but
there are some budget schedules
on
okay
um all right well why don't
you give us you know like five minutes
of highlights of things that have
changed from what you've talked about
before thank you Mr chair it's a
pleasure to be U before you and your
committee again my name is Jan Goodwin
and I am the executive director of the
New Hampshire retirement system here
with me today is Marie Mullen our
Director of Finance in the audience is
Diana kryon from our legal staff our
mission is to provide secure retirement
benefits and Superior Service for those
who have seen nhs's presentation before
the message is the same while we still
have some challenges in front of us we
are pleased with the Positive f funding
progress we have made and the
operational improvements which have been
implemented over the past several years
the nhrs board and staff are committed
to promoting the S sustainability and
stability of the retirement
system consistent with our prior
presentations we have two handouts a
budget overview with highlights
initiatives strategic challenges and a
highlevel budget outline and a copy of
our strategic planning document which
will speak to our goals the nhrs
statutory administrative budget which
does not include any funding from the
general fund encompasses all internal
non-investment related Administration
costs including projected it costs at
full value our statutory administrative
operating budget for fy2 is 13.6 million
and our budgets for fisal years 26 and
27 are 19.3 million and 19 .5 million
respectively based on fully Staffing all
board authorized positions these amounts
do not include General funds recomended
by the governor to cover group two
benefit changes nhs's budget was created
as part of a three-year strategic plan
to address deferred initiatives in areas
put on hold over the past five years due
to the focus on the major upgrade to our
20-year-old pension Administration
software the increase is primarily
driven by it upgrades modernization
projects and salaries and benefits to
support new staff positions aligned with
the Strategic
plan as you probably know the New
Hampshire retirement system is not an
executive branch agency but is a
statutorily created pension trust
although its expenses flow through the
state those costs are reimbursed from
the retirement trust which is in turn
funded by contributions from employers
and members and and investment Returns
the budget is before you today has been
fully vetted and adopted by our Board of
Trustees who are responsible for
approving a budget which is appropriate
for the system before I go into greater
detail on the operations of the oper
retirement system I would like to share
these key facts and HRS provides a
modest pension benefit these benefits
help support the New Hampshire economy
and there's a plan in place to pay down
the unfunded
liability and the trustees continue to
strengthen the plan by adopting revised
Actuarial assumptions recommended by our
actuaries and so at this point I will
turn to our budget document which you
have before
you just a few highlights that we had
discussed last time to reinforce um
earlier I'm on page three of the handout
um the board certified the employer
contribution rates for fiscal years 26
and 27 and this was the second
consecutive 2-year rate cycle which has
seen a decrease in employer contribution
rates we um issued our June 30 2024
financial statements and the gby 68 and
70 reports 75 reports with unmodified
clean
opinions on page four you can see the
continued positive trajectory of our
funded ratio and at the same time our un
unfunded liability is continuing to be
amortised we on page five we realized an
88.8% return on investments which SE um
and that translate into US performing
better than 70% of our peers over the
past
decade on page
six we ramped the strategic planning
process and developed a three-year
strategic plan for fiscal years 25 and
27 which is in your materials the board
also agreed to modify the fund's asset
allocation reducing the allocation to
Global equities from 50% to 40% and
increasing the allocation of to private
credit by 5% and allocating 5% to
private
infrastructure and we continue to
maintain and expand cyber security
enhancements to protect the security of
our system as well as our members and
retirees personal
information page seven so what's ahead
of us we want to build on our pension
Administration system implementation by
monitoring member and employer service
levels and developing a long-term plan
for future service enhancements and we
continue to review and adjust as needed
the Investment Portfolio to meet or
exceed the Retirement Systems assumed
rate of return of 6.7% 5% over the long
term while at the same time managing
risk return and
liquidity as you all know there's been
many bills in the last few years which
have affected nhrs there were eight
bills that were implemented in the
2023 24 legislative session and several
of the benefit related changes required
significant pension database
modifications page eight Begins the
budget part of the presentation and I
will now turn the floor to Marie Mullen
our Director of
Finance thank you very much on page
eight um we have um actuals for the last
three years 2022 23 and 24 as you can
see we had our actual expenditures
remained fairly flat the increases we
had were primarily related to our
pension gold upgrade um that was our
five plus year uh pension system upgrade
that we completed last
year on page nine um just some
highlights of the the operating budget
um again as executive director Goodwin
mentioned the budget was approved by the
Board of
Trustees uh the governor's recommended
budget did include General funds related
to the hb2 provision for group two
members that included 5 million in
fiscal year 26 and 27.9 million in
fiscal year 27 those are the only
General funds um in our budget at this
time um we created our budget as part of
our three-year strategic plan um again
as executive director Goodwin mentioned
um we had put several initiatives and
upgrades on hold due to the um for the
past five years to focus on our pension
upgrade and this budget reflects some of
those overdue projects that need to be
updated and completed to ensure Superior
Service to our members and also security
as um was mentioned
earlier so the two-year budget um of
71.6 million includes a 78% increase o
for fiscal year 26 over fiscal year 2025
and a 95% increase for fiscal year 2027
over fiscal year
2026 that's primarily driven by the
group two benefit changes it upgrades
modernization projects and salaries and
benefits to support new staff positions
aligned with the Strategic plan so if
you turn to page 10 we have um a general
overview of the budget that we submitted
for our agency budget and then as a
comparison against the governor's budget
the only change um in the governor's
budget was in line 12 in the retiree
Healthcare and those were the general
funds that were added um for the group
two benefits um change that is in
hb2 um 5 million was added in fiscal
year 2026 again in 27.9 million in
fiscal year
2027 um on line two our salaries and
benefits um we do see an increase there
that is related to uh wage
increases and also new positions um
primarily in it we have several new
positions around security movement to
the cloud um and project managers to
support um some of the the new the
delayed initiatives that we had for our
technology and software technology
software and Hardware line on line four
the increase there is primarily for
projects again that were delayed due to
PG that um includes moving to Microsoft
cloud um we have additional pension gold
enhancements and maintenance of the
current system for pension gold as well
as an upgrade to our website um we are
looking to do a mobile app for our um
members and also an upgrade to our
financial software um which is uh a 2017
version and is no longer being supported
by Microsoft so we need to upgrade that
as
well
um I will open it up to the committee
now for any questions so
so this um salary and benefits I mean
this is a huge increase here
um of uh 25% or something like that is
that what how many more employees how
many employees do you have now and how
many more will you get so we have 78
currently and we are adding nine
positions in 2026 and three in
2027 and again those positions are
primarily it around to ensure security
so that's to the movement to the cloud
uh project manager position a business
analyst these are all things with the
the new software that we had we did not
have the right Staffing in this area and
now we're trying to improve that so that
we can maintain our systems security and
those type of
things representative C thank you Mr
chair what's the justification for the
health care going up 500% in
2027 I I no no this is the sor
I'll answer this this is the group two
enhancements this is not the stuff in
yellow yeah is not real that that's part
of that's the extra money for for the
police and fire retirement system right
the the the governor all right okay so
what happened was in our previous two
years ago in our budget we had a big
increase for for the retirement system
of police fire and Corrections okay
the Senate cut that in half they took
only the employees that were in the
system like 10 plus years okay but they
avoided giving anything to current
employees or the younger employees this
is for those employees right so it's not
but their real budget is this 41%
increase right so that's the extra 12
employees on top of 78 plus plus uh um
salary
increases yes okay is that correct yes
right so so you're getting new software
and that new software is causing you to
spend even more
employees more money on employees right
I mean isn't software supposed to make
things easier I think the the the new
employees are to support current systems
as well we identified that the current
Staffing we have for the the systems
that we have with the new upgrade we did
we did not have sufficient funding so
this is right sizing that but then also
with the new applications that are
coming on being able to support that we
do have temporary funding in here as
well so we recognize that some of these
projects are shortterm and that we only
need folks to help support the
implementation so we have some temporary
that would then be released like
temporary um help or Consultants so we
do not not we are not fully Staffing to
to complete all of this and then have to
lay off folks this is what we deem we
need to be able to
maintain the systems um appropriately to
be able to handle the the new um
products the new security requirements
the changes that come with it constantly
that need to be monitored to make sure
the funds of our retirees are secure and
safe as well represent
run thank you Mr chair
as far as the Staffing
goes did you look at instead of putting
someone on the payroll as a as an
employee did you look at maybe having
those contracted
positions um yes as um Finance
director um
Mullen um stated in in her commentary
whenever possible we look to see is this
a long-term need or a short-term need
and then um build the project
accordingly so we do have there will be
some temporary employees and also we
there are some employees that we will be
needing on a permanent
basis yes go ahead okay so the um nine
employees you're adding in 26 and the
three that you're adding in 27 do those
include those temporary employees those
are
full-time they would be um group one I
would assume corre they would all be all
the employees at nhrs are group one okay
thank you so roughly how much um money
is given to you uh for uh employ for
retirement
savings systemwide every
year all the retirement you know the the
all the payments employer and
employee for all all of all over um it's
approximately $900
million okay so um so your expenses on
that 900 million are are 20
19 is that what we're talking about here
so those are administrative expenses but
we have um also the investment side that
is not included in here so we have
investment we have Investment Management
fees those other pieces so when you look
at the administrative costs compared to
all of our fees and costs it's less than
1% of the fees are related to our
administrative
costs overall in the
system your administrative costs are 2%
of the
total being invested every year yeah
it's not 2% of of the Corpus right but
it's 2% of the activity sort of so
you're you're only taking into account
the contributions you're not taking into
account the investment gains as as well
right we have our the investment
as well and the investment gains from
the system as well yeah but that doesn't
cause administrative expense so all
right
um okay so let's talk about the uh the
the group two enhancements why is it
only 5 million the first
year that is a good
question you don't know we do not know
okay all
right um go ahead repr again this was
the the governor's this was the
governor's recommended budget Who would
know because it's quite because it's
supposed to be for the full year isn't
it or you don't know yeah this was the
governor's recommended
budget so the her budget director would
be the one that would know where the
number came from
yes so in your budget in fiscal year
2024 actual Personnel Services
non-benefit was 7
million 7, 236,000 what what was that
for and it now it's going down to
essentially
zero that's class 45 on page
155 um
okay that um is related to um a TSA 7.1
million was related to the $500 one-time
payment that the um legislature that was
approved in law um so so that was a cola
yeah so the way yeah the way the state
has to transfer the funds they put it
through our operating budget so that's
why that looks so large thank you other
questions representative Lehman
thanks Mr chairman good morning so a
followup to the Chairman's question
about the $5 million what about the 20
what $9 million or what 27 million do
you have any idea where that number came
from or is that the governor's number as
well um that is also the govern's number
um it's our understanding that this is
from the um the video Lottery terminals
a share of that
Revenue haven't been proved yet correct
okay but all right thank you thank you
Mr
chairman now that I don't understand
because this is an expense I think I
thought that was the group two expense
no for for Mr chair it is the group to
expense but there is a bill um Senate
Bill 83 which would provide for um
Revenue being um dedicated a portion of
the revenue from the video
Lottery terminals would be directed to
NH HRS but that's not in here because
this says general
funds yeah I believe the the bill as
written in hb2 directs the video Lottery
terminals to those funds to be directed
to the general fund there's nothing
specific that it gets directed to nhrs
sure um in the hb2 bill for the group
two benefits it does state that 2 7.5
million per year for 10 years would be
directed would go to in general funds to
the retirement system I'm not sure why
this is 27.9 but we're assuming that
it's based on that 27 a. half million
from the the bill that was as it was
presented okay all right any other
questions represent
R thank you Mr chair um there's a line
here um it was on training employee
training
um is that for the software or why oh
okay um the employee training is um It's
a combination of items for our for our
staff so we have um we allow them you
know folks to have training to better
them their selves what they may need to
do their jobs at nhrs we also provide um
college assistance College tuition
assistance for employees um as well as
attending conferences again to better
themselves so okay so that training
includes College yes oh okay um follow
Mr chair I I'm just wondering so those
seem pretty consistent that should be
consistent year-over-year but there is
an increase um you know 100,000 over 24
that's proposed for
26 um why why is that
jump so during our pension gold upgrade
um for a year year and a half we had
during 2024 we had a moratorium on folks
being able to go to training take
training um and some of these you know
folks were working so they didn't take
their education classes so they've been
kind of delaying that as well so this is
um for folks we're now seeing starting
to um initiate and act take additional
training again going to classes and that
type of thing so we're anticipating that
increase since we had had that
moratorium um during the pension gold
upgrade okay thank you so Melissa are we
authorized to change this I mean if if
we don't to have 12 new employees just
six or something like that or not you
are authorized to change their budget I
see okay representative
wer I'm looking through here to find the
rates the employer pays for police and
fire in group two and I don't see him
here
yeah that's
right um Mr chair um representative um
wer um for group two for fiscal year
24 25 was
31.2% for police and
30.354701
15% for
fire is that in this piece
no and the the employee Shares are still
about 11 something
yes the employee share for police is
11.55% and for fire it's
11.8%
11.8
okay seems like
that it's out of line there should be
more of a
sharing with all that
cost yeah so that's like 40% total and
then you then you put the health
insurance on top of that
and it's over
50% benefits
line probably
60% all right so I I don't think we'll
make any decisions about this budget
today but we'll say thank you very much
and we'll we'll read the details and
maybe we'll have to come back later
thank you all right so let's move on
to um Community Development Finance
Authority
which are on
page 18 138
this is page
138 that
138 and there's only one little thing in
there all right thank you there is uh
thank you very much good morning Marty
yeah I'm Katie easterly Marty with the
Community Development Finance Authority
I'm the executive director and Ian Hart
is our Chief Financial Officer thank you
for the opportunity to address you this
morning regarding State Treasury
Department's Budget on page 138 for
fiscal years 26 and 27 which is New
Hampshire's required match for
administration of the federal Community
Development block grant also known as
cdbg I do have a presentation that I
provided and if uh in your paper-clipped
packet it's the second of that that I'll
go through which has some visuals that
will uh provide some information about
what the Community Development block
grant program is so the Community
Development Finance Authority is a state
chartered independent nonprofit
organization our board is appointed by
the governor and Council as a state
Authority we are among a handful of
unique entities that work in partnership
with state and federal initiatives to
strengthen New Hampshire's Community
communities through the distribution of
resources to municipalities nonprofits
and businesses
cdbg the Community Development block
grant which we administer was
established by the Housing and Community
Development Act of
1974 and the primary goals are to
develop viable communities to provide
decent housing and suitable living
environments and to expand economic
opportunities through an annual formula
from the Department of Housing and Urban
Development there's cdbg funds to the
States cdfa has administered the annual
allocation of cdbg funds on behalf of
the State of New Hampshire since 2003
we're coordinating the investment since
2003 of over $200 million into New
Hampshire's communities every year cdfa
deploys approximately $9.4 million of
Community Development block
grants the illustration that looks like
an arrow sort of describes how these
block grants come to New Hampshire the
funding is allocated from HUD to cdfa
cdfa then Awards those funds to a
municipality and then the municipality
often Works alongside a subrecipient to
administer the funds and ultimately they
benefit individuals across all of our
communities for more than 20 years cdfa
has provided the state with an
exceptionally coste effective system for
administering these Federal resources
the cdbg program is uh focused on
developing viable sustainable
communities by providing housing decent
living environments and expanding
economic
opportunities the picture with the map
on it shows all of the communities in
red that received Community Development
block grants last
year in the past two years the Community
Development block rant program assisted
30,239 people through public services
and public facility
improvements created or retained 37 jobs
rehabilitated or preserved 400 48
housing units and provided technical
assistance to over 540 small
businesses I'll illustrate a couple of
those projects now as a flavor of what
the block grants do um can we skip more
to uh numbers yeah
please so our budget requests um is
280,000 each year for two 2026 and 2027
a total request of $560,000
which is approximately
2.9% which allows us to provide the
technical assistance guidance
Contracting and other administrative
requirements of the federal funds to
leverage around $19 million we received
the exact amount annually uh into New
Hampshire's
communities I'd be happy to answer any
your questions about the budget request
or any of the information that I
presented so so the match is only 3% or
something is that
yes all right
representative Ms and then
representative W thank you thank thank
thank you Mr chair and um sorry I joined
your joined you late um so if I
understand correctly if we don't make
this um if we if we don't provide
funding for $560,000 we would lose this
$19 million Federal allocation that's
correct and wouldn't and would therefore
not be able to make the kind of
investments in the community that we've
been doing okay thank thank you
yes representative
W uh thank you
so is there any followup on these
projects to ensure that they are
completed as requested yes absolutely so
we do a desk monitoring and then we do
actually an on-site monitoring where we
ensure not only that the projects
completed but that also it meets all the
federal requirements because we are
audited in ually a financial audit and
then we're also audited by the federal
government to ensure that the funds are
appropriately expended in community so
we want to support municipalities often
they're volunteer staff and they need
the support to be able to use federal
funds so we provide them that training
and then we do the monitoring to ensure
that they've met all the requirements
thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr chair how many
employees do you have we have 18 18 are
they all full-time uh no no what do you
know what the breakout is uh 16
full-time and uh two part-time okay yep
so I thought you said that our part is
the administrative cost right so this
doesn't pay for 18 we administer other
programs as well state tax credit
program the Community Development tax
credit program as well as some loan
programs and other things that the state
needs us to do in order to create uh
viable communities support that's not
part of the $9 million I see thank you
represent of you I see you've uh
supported a lot of housing projects but
I was wondering how you um what your
prioritization is in your Grant making
or or or what the process is um and just
as a general comment I think that this
money is incredibly well leveraged thank
you so much so every year uh we actually
have public hearings to give input into
our prioritization and then there's a
scoring system it's both uh quantitative
as well as qualitative data that creates
that scoring it's publicly available um
the scoring so all applicants will know
what that scoring criteria is before
they apply and then it gets adjusted as
the conditions change and the data
suggests uh that different priorities
should be made but there's a definite
focus on housing as well as public
facilities which are things like uh
Child Care Facilities nonprofit Child
Care fac facilities would be considered
a public facility
I don't yet representative MCH so again
forgive me it's it's early still and
I've only had one cup of coffee
um I I I guess I'm I'm confused there's
you said you have 18 employees but I
don't see anything in the budget detail
that indicates that you have any
positions right so we're a Public
Authority so we're an independent
nonprofit but you provide this um
required State match and then on behalf
of the state we administer through
contract
follow up yeah and so the the the
$280,000 that um you'll you get I mean
what is that used for so it's for all
the staff that provide the uh guidance
to to um applicants that do the
monitoring that do the payments it's for
our systems so we actually leverage the
staff across all the programs um so that
it's a portion of those activities and
we're putting activities of Community
Development together to be sure that we
can do all that all those pie okay so
that's why it's kind of cost effective
is because it's not only for the block
grant program but we're able to have one
staff person who's dedicated for
instance to Federal monitoring but is
doing that learning that activity and
then doing across a couple different
program areas but that can't possibly
cover all your administrative costs so
some of them some of those
administrative costs are coming out of
the federal money correct um so there is
uh some federal money that goes for the
administrative cost but we also
administer other programs so it's the
fees together that cover our our staff
okay all right so uh representative eel
is recognized for a motion thank you
thank you very much um Mr chair um based
on the presentation that was given the
incredible leveraging that is possible
through this program um I think it's a
great benefit to the state and I'd like
to move that we accept uh their budget
as presented and if I need more detail
from the budget book please feel free to
add to my
motion all right seconded by
representative rung any discussion of
this
motion all right clerk do we call a roll
on this kind of thing or show of hands
show show a hands okay all those in
favor please raise your hand okay any
oppose it's unanimous all right thank
you very much for coming thank you very
much
e
e e
and am I'd like to open up a work
presentation session by The Liquor
Commission uh that can be found on page
304 of the budget uh
welcome thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee Joseph Mica chairman of
the New Hampshire Liquor Commission and
with me is our CFO Tina
deir representative Maguire just handed
us some questions so we'd be happy to go
through those first if you'd like that
would be great thank you okay thank
you um first the handout that we
provided good morning the handout that
we provided um is just to show the
difference between what we propos for
cuts and what are in the governor's
budget um they took all of the cuts that
we recommended except for when going
through the numbers um we found that a
couple of the numbers provided by doit
they had already accounted for one
position in the agency phase so when
they provided the number to us it
couldn't be reduced again and then there
were two positions that they provided
funding for us about 300,000 and those
positions aren't actually direct to
liquor they're actually Statewide doit
positions so we couldn't reduce them
from our budget so you'll see that the
numbers that we proposed and the
governor numbers are about $500,000
different yes representative mons thank
you so the um and thank you for being
here and taking my question so the the
governor's budget numbers include those
positions is that correct well the the
two positions are Statewide so they're
not actually in Liquor's budget so we
couldn't cut them and then the other
position they already cut in our budget
in um the agency phase so they were
already reduced prior
to so the positions weren't exclusive to
liquor so we can't take them out of our
project there we have some direct
positions from doit and then there are
the shared positions so we couldn't take
the funding for those positions that
they identified originally as positions
for us and those the shared positions
represent I I guess I'm trying to
understand the
um so the the governor's budget had for
for doit has $500,000 more than what you
had proposed correct and and that and is
that $500,000 those positions correct
you really don't want them they're not
really part of yours but that's where
they ended
up is that correct yeah yeah okay thanks
just quick question so the 528 104 like
I'm looking at here that's your share of
the shared
positions is that the number I'm looking
under doit like difference to the agency
FY the 512 or yeah and the five okay
right 528 and 528 those your share the
Liquor's share of the shared positions
no what DOI he did was they gave us the
numbers like they were positions that
were direct reports to liquor and they
weren't so we couldn't reduce them from
our budget because they're actually
Statewide shared positions gotcha so
they're dealing with it in the doit
budget okay
gotcha yes representative water but are
you in fact paying for the shared
positions totally no no we're only
paying for our share of three people
they reduced one they they took one out
in the agency phase so we're no longer
paying for that one that one was already
reduced and then they're removing the
positions in the doit funding so we
won't have to be paying a share for
those positions but it seems Seems
expensive for three people
500,000 yeah thank you oh that's
salaries and
benefits
okay so the questions that we have in
front of us um the first one expenses up
16% or 16 million over uh 24 actual um
if you
look that is because we started um
budgeting for the transfer for HHS
whereas before it was a transfer number
after our revenues we actually stuck it
in our I shouldn't say stuck we put it
in our budget um so if you go to page
it's under
1030 if you go to page
315 you'll see um class 49 transfers to
other state
agencies we included the 17.8 million in
24 which was the actual transfer and
then you have the estimates for 25 26
and 27 so that's the increase because it
wasn't a line a budget line item in the
past it was a transfer after our
revenues so to make it clear and visible
we put it into the
budget for many many years it was kind
kind of tough accounting on it so Tina
decided to put it in that way and I
agreed with her that way we can clearly
see those numbers as their as their line
item now in the
budget uh page 304 oh sorry Mr
chair yes representative MZ so so what
is that for you you said something about
HHS those are the transfers to HHS for
the two transfer laws um the first one
is the 17616 which is 5% of our prior
year gross profit transferred to the
alcohol fund and then the other one is
the 126 AA which is for granted
advantage and that's based on numbers um
requested by HHS for the Medicaid
expansion okay
so the next question was on page 304 are
we done with consultants and the answer
to that is yes we had brought on
Consultants to H help with the um
d365 system in the transition and we
brought back uh a couple of the part-
timers to help with our old system to
our new system and now that we have
transitioned we would no longer be using
Consultants
enforcement salaries up 20% from 2024
this is on page
305 so we have um we had reported in our
in our last presentation that uh class
50 went up we brought on part-time
positions for our loss prevention
program in our stores which has been
very successful helping with trespass
orders and keeping the the customers and
the employees safe and then it's also
um the pay raise and benefit
increases then we have on page 38 what
is nabca Ward 150 annual
equipment so nabca is the national
alcohol beverage Association Council we
get a grant from them to help with
um underage drinking initiatives and the
equipment line is they were looking to
replace their golf cart
simulator that they take on the road to
high schools to show them impair
driving
yep okay so the next one is federal
funds jumping um is that accurate on
page
309 that is correct we did receive or um
we have a proposed contract with the FDA
for the tobacco compliance
and they did provide additional
funding um page
310 it just says information big number
can I think it's
Source on page
310 so is it the increase from 24 to 25
we are not projected to spend that whole
5.9 million and you'll see in 26 and 27
it has decreased to 4.6 and 4.7 okay
thank you for that so yes it was because
we've been told that that the fiscal
year 2025 adjusted authorized column is
the most accurate data that we know of
right and so are you not spending that
this year is that the that is correct
because if you look at our FY 24 spend
we're going to be more in line with the
24 spend than what we were provided for
the 25 adjusted authorized all right
thank thank you so so Melissa some of
these numbers have not been
updated right you told me that all these
numbers are now current right they were
updated as a point of time I will get
the point in time that they were updated
I did not have that part of it but it is
the um in in some I don't think I don't
know if you guys have fiscal items but
the fiscal year 25 adjusted authoriz
will include hb2 it will include fiscal
item dollars what it doesn't account for
is what is going to be lapsed or not
spent great okay thank you go
ahead uh so the next one was page
312 um 13 more
positions or 13 more employees 50% in
finance admin um we reported on our last
presentation that we actually moved
positions from other divisions to
support our new system
so that's the increase in the positions
but there were just moved from other
divisions uh page 314 why large increase
in Personnel merchandising especially
benefits with two
fewer so the benefits are based on the
current positions so we've had people
leave in the marketing and Merchandising
Division and other people have come in
um I believe the people that left were
single and I believe the people that
have come in are with families so that
has a huge increase in the benefits
gotta
okay uh page 315 store salaries up 15%
when countdown
4.5 um that is the pay raise and the
benefits the 12% pay raise that we
identified in our uh previous
presentation that was a significant
amount you had we had I believe it was
3.5 in um class 10 and another 3 million
in class 50 because we also increased
the pay rate for our part- timr to bring
in people at a higher pay to help
compete with the private sector gotcha
okay uh okay so page 315 why increase in
transfer to class 49 as I described
that's the transfer to HHS for the
alcohol fund and granted advantage and
contracts the increase in contracts is
for our new system so we've decreased
ined our doit budget um but we had to
increase contracts to bring on the
support and maintenance for our new
software system the d365 because doit
can't handle um maintaining the
system let me ask back to line 49 are
you saying granted Advantage is brand
new no um I explained I'm sorry you
weren't in the room we used to transfer
that not as a budget it was an
unbudgeted item and it caused a lot of
confusion so we decided in this budget
cycle to include it as a budget line
item item so you'll see we included 24s
actual that we transferred and then
what's projected for 25 26 and
27 yes so it's a lot more transparent so
again so the 5 million is missing from
24 but it was transferred or just no
it's increasing it's just increasing so
24 is what we actually transferred the
17 million and they're projecting the 23
million need in 26 and
27 oh so it's not a fixed percentage of
your so the
17616 is the 5% of the prior year gross
profit and that's the alcohol abuse and
prevention fund it's the 126 AA which is
for the granted Advantage Medicaid
expansion that one is based on hhs's
need to have the um match for the
non-federal
funding
great and they can also request on a
quarterly basis if they see a shortfall
in that account they can request more
funds which they've done for this year
of another 1 to two million okay thank
you I'm hoping to cancel all this stuff
by the way and just leave this in the
general f all right um so page 318 and
and back to 103 oh 103 and that's the
new systems the maintenance and support
for our new d365 that replaced our
mapper there was no real overhead cost
for the prior system and this system now
being
cloud-based requires um more maintenance
and support and doit can't support it so
we had to go outside for contracts for
that so you basically had a 40y old
system for many for obviously that many
years that had two people part- timers
maintaining it and helping us keep it
running and price changes Etc the new
system is d365
Microsoft cloud-based and there's
expenses that are incurred along along
with that but it's performing better
it's performing very good at this point
there's we're not even a year into it we
launched it last April so obviously as
you go through the first year of any new
system it has its glitches and we've
worked through them and we're pretty
happy with what we've done and we we
think in the future you'll see the
benefits of those expenses got more
efficiencies yeah okay thank you um page
318 um workers comp declining is that
correct yes the numbers for workers comp
were provided by risk management and
were based on um the historical
Trend excellent we had a a real Spike um
in two years where we were really
pushing our employees hard during covid
and there were a lot more you know back
injuries and stuff like that and now
that you know we've streamlined that and
we also risk management brought on a new
insurance company and they've been
fighting a lot more claims than just
paying them out like the prior one did
so that has an impact okay we also only
have six six stores that are hand unload
now we're in the past we had 40 or 50
stores that are hand unload everything's
pallet unload done mechanically so safer
saes absolutely terrific representative
Ms for a question is your um is your
workers comp program
um a standalone for the Liquor
Commission or is it integrated with
other state agencies it's through risk
management through the state okay thank
you other kind of book related question
you know
hb1 line by line kind of questions yes
representative
EV um thank you it's not an enormous
amount of money but on page 309 uh where
there's the FED funds line that uh the
chair asked about and I see it's an FDA
tobacco I assume that's a grant
um just as a general question what are
you hearing about that were your was the
source of funds cut off do you hope it's
going to continue any concerns about
that at this point we've heard nothing
about nothing and and I will say that
when they have cuts at the federal level
this we have a one position that is um
tied to this actual contract so we call
it a grant but it's actually a contract
so when there are Cuts with the feds
this is not impacted because it's not
considered a grant we've always checked
in on that when they were doing cuts at
the federal level and they said no the
way that this is structured it's it's a
contract
agreement with the federal government
with the FDA yeah so is this to make
sure that people aren't selling
cigarettes to minors is that the whole
idea here yes correct okay tobacco
compliance check yep gotcha
okay other questions representative
lean so good morning so my periodic
question is that the declining Revenue
issue when you were here a month or so
ago we talked about it and I just looked
at the governor's U projected numbers
and for 25 she's got like 92 coming out
as far as Revenue back to the State
however the revenue estimates for uh
26 or somewhere in the neighborhood of
115 million are you confident with that
increase because you not no fault of
your own I guess but you've seen a
declining Revenue base and yet she's
looking at Revenue numbers that are
substantially
positive we talked to the governor's
budget director and he believes that the
26 27 numbers are more based on changes
for transfers to HHS for the changes in
the eligibility for the Medicaid
expansion and for some prescription drug
um changes and that they think that that
will realize a greater transfer to the
general fund versus
HHS that will and that impact your
budget in a positive way is that what
you're that would reduce the transfer to
HHS and would increase the transfer to
the general fund okay I do agree with
the chair I think at some point we need
to look at uh the way the money the 5%
because there's no oversight whatsoever
on that money it just goes out and there
a lump sum without any sort of budget
being presented yeah my thought is
simply to take those two transfers out
and make them division 3's problem
to to find the money right yeah that's
where it really should be I guess yeah
that's what I think I I I'm just really
against automatic spending you know what
I mean programmed we agree yeah okay um
but yeah so we'll get to that in a
minute okay so um so generally then just
as far as the liquor business goes
You're Expecting relatively flat sort of
results is that it yeah I would say that
flat is the new up so very
happy because uh the trend in general is
down right and drink less drinking more
more as cannabis well the trend in
general is down and for the reasons that
we've gone through cannabis and uh the
Baby Boomers aging out of the market and
the health piece as well you know and U
surgeon drenal comes out and the and uh
comes out and says that any amount of
alcohol is in safe and causes cancer
that's a problem so people are uh being
very cautious about how much they drink
uh they're drinking better but they're
not drinking as much and you know the
three states around us uh we we can't
have a a candid conversation about the
decline of alcohol without speaking
about cannabis Massachusetts in
2024 did 1.6 billion in cannabis sales
and Maine did about 800 million Vermont
did about 300 million 72 million in tax
to the to the state coffers in
Massachusetts from that 1.6 billion U
you know it's a new industry that's
flourishing and alcohol is taking the
hit and it's happening Nationwide it's
we just happen to be in a very unique
situation here in New England now when
you said drinking better do you mean
going moving up in quality higher priced
uh uh Liquors I guess yes we don't
necessarily see people shopping the
bottom two shelves they're shopping the
the the higher end liquor so they're
willing to spend $100 50 to $125 a
bottle but they're not they're not
buying that amount of alcohol on a
weekly basis so it's more of a special
occasion kind of thing and
premiumization is something that grew
during uh
uh Co and has leveled up off but it's
still there and something that we're
recognizing that's why our sales we have
changed the way we're doing sales you're
not seeing as many of the case sales
you're seeing the twer and the fourer
sales which are driving the business
back into the state gotcha okay
representative
Le thanks Mr chairman so I know grocery
stores like Market Basket charge self
space um for the products you must do
the same thing you mentioned like the
premium eye Lev type of product versus
something that's lower shelf so that um
bottler is paying the liquor store for
space on that shelf as well as or not no
no so you can't charge there's there's a
term and I I I won't be able to think of
it as we're speaking but I can get it to
you it's uh federally prohibited to
charge for uh space Oh really for liquor
at one point in the in the liquor
commission's history they tried to do it
with our floor planner a monthly floor
planner to charge for the more premium
spaces yeah and we were uh we were told
by the federal government that you can't
do it and and you can't do it oh isn't
that interesting thanks Mr chairman
thank you why don't we get into some of
my big question so um where are the
worst performing stores
maybe well during the thank you during
the covid uh pandemic we closed about
four 12 or 13 stores maybe as many as 14
we were up in the mid 80s we're now down
in the mid 60s but there's still a
couple of stores that are marginal
they're profitable but they're marginal
Walpole would be
one Woodsville would be one and then you
could you could potentially add oopy and
wolfb into that equation what we're
doing is looking at the oopy wolf borrow
now for maybe a consolidation of those
stores into one store and that's really
what we did during Co and found some
additional savings during that period of
time but those were the the top two
would be uh Walpole and Woodsville so
wple would start shopping in Keane or
something like that yeah so the brand
new Keane store is just a few miles away
so okay but that's something that's
constantly on your radar for we we look
at it pretty much on a quarterly basis
to see what stores are performing and
which stores we feel are underperforming
the biggest thing when when we say
underperforming today in retail is are
the customers happy with the product
selection and because of the increased
square footage that we've done in 40
plus stores that's what people expect
when they go into a store to go into a
small store that's you know doesn't have
the skus or stocking units that
consumers are uh underwhelmed they want
to shop in the bigger stores because
that's where the selection is so we're
seeing as time goes on the attrition of
these smaller stores is just a natural
progression right
so thank you Mr chair um when you were
here for the um introduction a month ago
you mentioned that some things that may
be on the horizon would be like delivery
or or mail liquor how much revenue so
obviously I would say that that's a um
Market strategy for competition
especially how much revenue do we get
from alcohol that is mail ordered but
originates from out of state so let's
say if someone belongs to a wine club
and they have wine delivered from
California or something how does that
Revenue get captured we we I assume we
get revenue from that how does that get
captured well the it's it's uh
lovingly called the John Hunt tax okay
all right it's an 8% premium tax that's
charged on anything that sh it's shipped
into the state and we track that through
UPS and FedEx through our enforcement
Division and that uh 1.2 $1.2 million in
2023 1.4 and 23 in 1.2 and
24 so I'm sorry could you give me those
what was it in 20 am I missing it on a
page or something no this is in our
annual report oh okay so it's 1.4 in 23
and 1.2 in
24 okay so it's going to see a slight
reduction okay and I think I asked this
of you last time but do we do any
regulation or tax collection on THC
drinks that are coming into the state
those are not controlled by the
commission at all there's no regulate
and it's it's a it's a nationwide issue
I mean there's no regulation on THC
cannabis drinks into many states and
many states are recognizing the problem
that it's creating because people are
able to go online and it was part of the
cannabis bill that failed last year part
of it was that was in there for the
Liquor Commission to regulate that as
well as we do instate shipments um but
without without that bill obviously not
only in this state but in many states
that's going unchecked okay so that
would have to be require Federal action
then well it certainly would require
State action of an agency and most
likely be the Liquor Commission to come
up some with some language in order to
oversee that properly okay and I just
want to remind you because I think we
had a conversation about this offline is
that some of the THC is derived from
hemp so if it's linked to cannabis we
would still miss the opportunities or
the the potential to tax THC drinks that
are originating from hemp rather than
cannabis it's m it's much like any of
the RTD drinks that are out there now
that are contain alcohol some of them
are malt-based some of them are spirits
based so it would be the same type of
language that we would need to have with
a cannabis based drink or a hemp based
drink okay thank
you so is this something you would like
to sell in the stores or no well I I
think some of it some of it is being
sold through the beer wholesalers but
the majority of it is being sold online
and shipped into the state and as we've
said it's it's an unregulated Revenue
source for the state so could we get
just that piece out of the last year's
Bill
maybe to just regulate that I mean would
you need presumably You' need more
employees to to to regulate it yeah well
there there'd be some oversight that
would be necessary I mean I I don't
think it would be a plethora of
employees it' probably be a couple more
in order to do that okay but that's a
potential Revenue Source okay all right
do you know what for those kind of
drinks what uh other states tax rates
are not off the top of my head Mr
chairman no but I could find out could
you find out absolutely thank you um
other questions set thank you okay
representative Ms um back back to the
question about um closing stores um do
you have any any data that would
indicate you know what the what the net
impact would be on on on your budget in
terms of um you know cost savings
Revenue loss Etc sure we we could we
could certainly do that but historically
the the uh the cost of closing a store
is is minimal and the the shift that's
why you know uh the chair mentioned Keen
if we close Walpole the people consumers
just buy in a different location uh the
locations are close enough by the new
location in Keen is right next to a
Market Basket that I'm sure everybody in
that area shops at so people when
they're there at Mark they may have to
change the times that they buy it might
not be as as quote unquote convenient
but when they're at Market Basket now
they're at the liquor store and they
just their shopping patterns are a
little different and the overhead for
these locations is minimal most of our
lower performing stores are ten in it
will and very very uh nominal square
footage
812 where in some of the bigger stores
we're paying a little bit more than that
12 14 16 but the impact is greater
because the sales are greater and
there's greater traff traffic flow and
and presumably in addition to saving the
um the the the rental expense um you
would you would save in terms of
personnel cost because you wouldn't need
to transfer those individuals would you
well the the full-time employees would
be transferred to to the to a
neighboring store okay that those
particular stores I'm off the cuff I'm
saying that Walpole may have two
full-timers and Woodsville probably the
same where're store like Keen uh could
have as many as 13 but probably runs
around
nine and are bigger stores open more
hours they are yeah so that's another
thing okay um any other okay let's talk
about uh licensing and enforcement um
how much of our Revenue do we get in
licensing fees and also fines so the
licensing fees are in 2024 we're 3.7
million and the same in 23 so about 3.7
million uh we
have the processing and investigation
fees or or I'm sorry administrative
fines are only like
142,000 and then we have the direct
shipping which we told you was uh 1.2
million and then there's the wine tax
which is about 300,00
,000 an overall enforcement overseas
around 6300
lies uh inst State out of state Direct
ship uh obviously our locations but on
premise off premise and we can give you
a breakdown of those if you'd like but
that's around the number that they
oversee
okay so when were licensing fees last
changed or it is it a constant thing uh
they haven't gone up in a long time as
far as the fees are concerned yeah okay
so we might we might be do is
that yeah right yeah I mean well I can
certainly tell you and I've always said
as a lensee in other states uh I held
licenses in New Jersey and Massachusetts
as well as New Hampshire New Hampshire's
fees have always been what any business
person would consider very reasonable
compared to the surrounding states okay
could you could you put
together it doesn't have to be all
hundred licenses but you know a couple
of sort of um
representative examples of Maine Vermont
New Hampshire sure and Massachusetts
yeah for comparison purpose yeah I I
just like to see the statute is the
statute where the fees are they are in
statute just whatever that
as well and don't and and and just for
transparency the licenses in Maine and
the licenses in Massachusetts and I
believe in Vermont are owned by the
license of the business and are
transferable as such New Hampshire is
not that way those licenses are renewed
on a yearly basis and not an asset of
the business they're certainly an asset
of the business as they run and enjoy
the prod profs of the alcohol but it's
not something that's it's a guarantee
we're in Massachusetts when you won't
buy a license you own that license and
it's an asset of the business New
Hampshire is not that way would we save
money if we made it not yearly but every
two years or three
years
perhaps yeah okay
of course I'm I'm going to say that
there' be a lot of people that
would understandably push back against
any types of fees I don't want to speak
for any other organizations but that's
always been something that's been a back
and forth when the Liquor Commission has
had that discussion over the years now
so the total cost of enforcement am I
right it
was is it 10 million a year or something
is that
or is it
five three
times but it seemed to me there were
kind of two sections that were both kind
of enforcement but maybe not so there's
enforcements overhead themselves which
is the 77 7878 accounting unit and then
they oversee the
grants that are listed underneath
so it's within their activity division
okay
so all right so it's mainly what we see
on page 310 this 5 million a year is
that
it liquor fund
line3 they're actually um on 306
the actual overhead for the operation of
enforcement enforcement which is the
4.78 in 25 and then the projection for
5.3 and 5.5 in 26 and 27 okay so what am
I seeing on page 310 is that an overall
number no yes that's that's that's for
their whole division
the enforcement Division and the grants
that they oversee that's within their
structure okay okay
good all right and part of that increase
we talked about in on the page 310 was
the increase in the federal money that
they're receiving couple hundred
thousand there
yeah right but but they're essentially
not really paying for themselves right I
me in they bring in about $13 million
well they bring in 13 million for the
beer tax and then the licensing which is
the other 3 million um if you look at I
don't know if you have the
presentation from the last
time not in front of me
is just the licensing piece of expenses
broken out or not
really for their the their budget
themselves so they bring in 13.3 million
in taxes the 4.2 million in
fees 142 in fines and then miscellaneous
so they're Revenue that they manage is$
million okay and then they oversee the
6,300 lienes yeah but probably most of
that is the beer tax which takes one or
two employees or something right I mean
it's but then they're out in the the all
of the establishments visiting all of
the establishments doing the education
and the training and the compliance
check compliance Che the alcohol
compliance checks the tobacco compliance
checks and any complaints that come in
from lenses or consumers legislature Etc
gotta okay all right
so um how
often is a ly like a like a restaurant
visited
they go ahead I think they tried they
tried to touch each license lensey uh
physically once a year to check on the
license itself but then there's
compliance checks which would be
additional so I would say that they get
to every ly two to three times a
year okay and helping new licenses
yep yes represent so I think you would
argue that the
compliance portion for enforcement is
quite important to ensuring that you get
the income I would say the compliance is
an important piece but I I think one of
the most important pieces that the
legislature has drawn us to over the
years is the education I mean
we're they visited a couple of hundred
high schools last year and did
demonstrations there they do the
underage driving um they do
all I can we I don't have it in front of
me but the amount of Education that they
do and stops that they make every year
is is uh is quite reasonable for the
amount of people that they have oh the
have your drive the little car with the
wavy glasses all this and testing and
and we and they test they they train and
test every lensey that has a new license
that comes up or anybody that's not in
compliance has to go back and have their
their employees retrained and then on on
premise sales from those establishments
is almost 100
million so I mean it's an important
piece of what we do and I I don't think
that you can have sales without having
compliance in education they go hand in
hand gotcha all
right other
questions no yeah represent
leishman so I the bottom number as far
as the number of employees you have was
like
371 and I noticed a lot of changes
um like on page
um you're going from number of positions
27 up to 40 I'm just kind of curious why
the Readjustment there and then under
for I'm sorry that's that's for the new
system okay yeah that we brought on do
some doit employees move them for the
oversight of the system and the help
desk in the human resource SE and I saw
there's quite an adjustment there page
313 going from 34 to
47 um that's in
total if you look up above HR is seven
employees when you look at the 34 to 47
that's for the whole division of
administration and that division of
administration oversees the new
financial management is that what I'm
yes I'm sorry yes financial management
Division and that includes do HR Finance
our legal department legal okay
Maintenance and Facilities but HR is
still only seven
employees okay so that increase from 34
to 46 is the one is for the finance for
the new systems we brought in employees
from store Ops and marketing and created
that new okay yeah I was just curious
where they came from to get there that's
all yeah so well you'll see that um
marketing em merchandising went down
that was down 14 to 12 and then store
Ops we took some um unfunded or vacant
positions there and moved them in to
help with the new system okay thanks
thanks Mr
chairman all right other
questions all right I guess we can go to
L chle today thank you thank you very
much thank you thank you for your time
you'll get us more information about
licensing fees and THC drinks maybe yes
them down okay and especially comparison
to other states and if we could have a
list like the stores perhaps they
mentioned Woodsville Walpole if there
are any others that should be on our
radar for Clos which I think makes sense
I just like to add as far as the fees I
guess to be a little sympathetic to The
Liquor Commission for a change
um I'm a little concerned if we um
increase fees it's just going to make
our Revenue collection even worse you
know we're struggling to meet plan for
fees now or revenue from The Liquor
Commission if we increase the fees that
may have a negative impact on returning
sales or whatever so thank you yeah I
mean but it it also depends on you know
sort of when fees were set and you know
cuz one of the fees I'm thinking about
we we'll get to later today the Bureau
of tax and land appeals I think they
said their fee was last set 50 years ago
right
so yeah and they didn't want to but you
know last time we didn't need cash quite
as bad as we do now so Mr chair I would
agree that across the uh agencies the
fees that have been Char a lot of them
haven't been updated since uh what is it
Hector was a pups so they were they're
worth uh they're worth considering and
looking at especially as we know when
revenue is down in other ways you got to
find ways to creative
ways so we'll be back at I think it's
[Music]
or or who's coming
up oplc oh no OPC okay very
good here could I just ask a yes go
ahead proc question so um I'm trying to
understand the schedule for the next two
or three weeks are you are we're not
meeting next two is it Tuesdays the day
we're not meting Tuesdays in general are
the days we're not going to be meeting
so okay so March 4th or okay that's a
Tuesday yeah so we're gonna meet Monday
Wednesday any available Thursday and
Friday okay okay so like next week
Thursday is available so we're meeting
and our goal is to try to get through
one pass of of our Pages by the end of
next week
okay and I don't know if Melissa thinks
we can do that or not yes So the plan is
to do that we are running into a little
bit of scheduling issues as next week is
school vacation for a lot of people so
there are some agencies that have said
we we're not available next week at all
so we might have to push some of those
off to the beginning that March 3rd
would be the hope to wrap that up if not
on Wednesday to at least have all the
agencies in and going through their
budget leaving us a couple of weeks to
get through and start making
decisions and at that point hopefully we
have HB
to in front of us and I'm just TR so
March 11th I think is town meeting day
don't we usually have that off we
normally don't schedule okay so that's
one two I'm just trying to figure out
all right thank you representative
Griffin my
birthday
e
e e
I and we are on page 159
159 159 yes
yeah it's like halfway down the
page yes yes I do see it sorry just the
page number was stuck in the
bindings
okay thanks for coming any do you want
to make any kind of opening remarks or
should we just dive into the details
I'll just introduce myself for the
record de jurus executive director of
oplc and with me is director of
operations Heather Kelly um happy to
take any questions we did uh try to
preemptively answer some of the things
either you've asked previously or um
that you had given us a heads up that
you were looking for um or other things
we thought were relevant but I'm happy
to just take questions if uh You' like
to go that route why don't we go through
the pages and then if you have things on
your list that we haven't gotten to then
you can add them absolutely so starting
on page
159 take a look at class line 30 next
second to the last yes so there's a lot
of equipment last bium and like nothing
this bium is that is that right for you
guys that is correct uh last byn we had
to replace our entire fleet U so that
was the cost last byn this year we do
not have to replace any of the vehicles
oh I didn't know you had Vehicles yes
for inspectors oh okay I see all right
good so that's that
one anybody else want to ask about this
page all right represent run thank you
Mr chair how many vehicles do you have
are they all passenger
vehicles yes all passenger vehicles uh
let me count my inspectors 15 I'm
looking at Heather I have 15 inspectors
that all have their own Vehicles so we
have 15
Vehicles all right and so um on the
basically in the same area but on this
it's really on the next page you have
four new
positions so are you
adding uh more responsibility is that
why you're
having oh from the 16 to the 20 right it
went from 16 to 20 yes so I I believe
that would account for we had um several
8 temporary positions that we had
requested become permanent positions and
that would three of the four I'm
confident are related to the hearings um
Bureau within the the office of
administration so that's two
administrative law judges and then a
hearings
clerk um and the fourth one I believe is
a project manager um within the
Operations Division to um try to work on
making sure that everything as the
office is um working on uh compliance
and we have multiple IT projects going
for a new licensing system hoping for a
new enforcement system as well um trying
to manage keep everything together so
those would be those four positions so
they're existing temporary with people
in them uh integral part of day-to-day
functioning that we're requesting to
become
permanent okay very good yes
representative W in uh
hb2 the governor transfers the uh
plumbing and electrical to safety so you
lose five mechanical and four electrical
I don't see that that's reflected so the
the 20 positions here is just the
division of administration so that's
executive director and operations those
nine positions are in the division of
enforcement presently yeah yeah we'll
get to that on page
162 so okay um good now on
page so what's the difference between
the administration division and the
licensing and board Administration
division so because the office is an
office and not a department there is
there's in it basically the office
consists of the administration which
would be the office of the executive
director in operations so we and then I
have a Licensing in board Administration
so those are the folks who are sitting
in board meetings with boards and then
the licensing service representative so
the ones on phones and emails and
issuing credentials
within the Licensing Division and then
the enforcement so um okay
yep and each one
has ah okay so why why does enforcement
have so many
unclassified the pharmacy inspectors
there are three Pharmacy inspectors that
are unclassified Personnel they're
appointed by governor and executive
counsel and that as a result the um it's
the budgeting for the position the
salaries does not uh the range is far
beyond the um classified system so they
have to be in that unclassified space so
it's the one division director and then
the three Pharmacy inspectors gotta so
the only other unclassified positions
are myself and then the director of
Licensing and administration so six
total okay and how many um those
Pharmacy inspectors how many pharmacies
do they inspect
I believe this is a a round number but I
believe it's
300 okay so it's like a 100 a piece or
something like that yeah
yes they also have a statutory
responsibility so any Heather will uh
correct me with the correct technical
term so uh facilities that have
Controlled Substances so that could even
be veterinary offices um any of those
there there's oversight and the
inspection um requirement there so it's
there are the standing pharmacies
Hospital pharmacies and then this other
very quite broad um reach don't you
okay representative Griffin thank you um
on page 160 line 531 and Pad programs
did you talked about them a little bit I
see the numbers unchanging over four
years yes that is uh what we call the
PHP the Prof professional health
professionals health program that is a
program it's a it's actually a dedicated
fund um that we have discussed over the
past several months with the dedicated
fund committee and others that is um a
requirement by Statute that uh lenses
Who Um can self-report and be referred
to this program for assistance with um
substance
misuse right representative Ms then
representative R thank you Mr chair
thank you for coming back to talk to us
um
on page 160 um Consultants uh there was
a significant jump from 24 to 25 and
that is staying at the same level what
what is
that um those would be uh consultants
for the division of enforcement so as
you're aware we have uh 57 different
boards um that we have investigators on
staff um and prosecutors so those
Consultants would be if there's
something specifically technical that we
need assistance within an
investigation um some of the fact
finding is fairly St forward if we have
a you a report of a DUI um some of these
other things are very clear on their
face if it's technical or involves scop
of practice we are often working with
Consultants to ensure that we have
adequate facts and investigation to
present to the
boards okay represent rung thank you Mr
chair also on that same page um the
indirect costs
040 um there was kind of a jump just for
uh 202 5 and then uh the same thing is
happening in
um oh transfer to other state agencies
could you go into more detail about that
I'm GNA have Heather Kelly address that
okay thank you originally in the
indirect cost in 2025 we have an
agreement with Department of Justice to
pay for a
dedicated um staff position 90% of a
paralal position and a part-time
position so that's why there's a jump um
we are then moving that cost back into
the sagap allocation instead of the
separate mou with
doj okay so the and I'm I'm a rookie
here so I can ask any question I want um
so the IND so what you're saying is the
the jump in the indirect costs are
because of sharing a position with doj
okay um and then why does that go back
down um uh we have transferred the cost
into the S cap analysis oh okay all
right and then the transfer to other
agencies
is that's uh
049 that is also part of the reason
correct and we had um various uh Comm uh
agreements with division of personnel
for HR Services I was able to negotiate
that down to a lower rate uh there were
some other M that we are no longer using
as well okay thank you you're
welcome how many lenses are there
total the total I'll give you a round
number so the in our last annual report
the total was 212,000 just over 212,000
lenses and is that going up or
down it's going down um but only in
recent history so the number was
extremely high during pandemic years
when um there was a lot of out of
licensure portability kind of exploded
and people were getting licenses
emergency licenses lots of changes there
I it's settling down um I don't have the
annual part in front of me but there the
trend from four years ago is down but
it's not
um yeah if that makes sense yes over the
long history I would not say it's
trending downward okay especially as we
had more license
types so that the fact that your budget
is relatively flat that's a good thing
what you're
thinking I mean your budget total looks
like 14 million
this 14 and a half yes yeah Fair yes
fairly close yep okay so how much is
that per
license that's like
uh 70 I don't don't have a calculator
but I'd be I'd happy to defer to
somebody's Mental Math yeah something
like that I think
I guess most lenses are
paying 15 for two years or something is
that what they do I would say that is
that would be high for many boards yes
um an RN in the state of New Hampshire I
think is $80 for two
years 100 100 for two years okay so
there must be some that are way up there
yeah so and APRN is 100 and RN is 80
yeah so uh this is off the top of my
head I think Pharmacy I think is
300 anyway there it varies uh and until
this past year um boards had the the fee
setting Authority for each of their
boards for their licenses that
responsibility Now lies with the office
to do fee analysis we talked a little
bit the last time that um Heather and I
were before this committee about um how
we're we're doing that assessment to
determine where the levels need to be
that
um yes to ensure that the costs are
adequately covered but not exorbitantly
so we we have a statutory requirement to
stay within 125% of our operation um our
estimated Revenue that is in the
presentation I'll touch on that here if
just as part of conversation um we we
are going to to propose a 10% increase
in licensing fees across all types and
then that expected revenue for the banum
would be 27 million
166,167 our expected expenses is 28
m752 so we're we're still about a
million dollar short so we are
definitely not at 125% even with a 10%
increase and even with a a cut actually
a lower
budget Mr chair yes are those are those
um increases assumed in this budget are
they reflected in this
budget the fee
the licensing the licensing fees would
be a fee proposal that would go in rule
before the joint legislative committee
on administrative rules so we that
revenue is controlled by that separate
committee so this is just the expenses
that you that you guys are hearing about
so again the proposed budget is is 28
and and change which is short of even
the 10% fee increase that we're um
planning to propose it's in in the
middle of an um impact analysis
presently fiscal impact analysis
are you going to have to come back next
a year from now for another increase
then to because you're still short I
don't hope so um the the plan I'm sorry
in my the handout that we
proposed on page
four the anticipation So currently oplc
is is at a net loss of just over a
million dollars for this fiscal year so
the the hiring frees the governor
instituted an executive order we had
kind of already lightly implemented even
over the last several months months
realizing that revenues were not keeping
up with expenses and um so hiring has
been slowed or paused even prior to that
executive order going out the office the
dedicated fund had a roll over at the
end of the last banum of um you can see
that number 4.5 almost 4.6 so the
remaining balance um has come down so
the plan would be to continue to use
that balance so that fees don't increase
further while we maintain a hiring
freeze until we get to a place that
we're that were
even any of your 89 positions
unfilled I
have I believe it is five I have a
number of positions that are frozen the
office also has um temporary positions
that are not allocated in this budget
the hope would be that when a new
licensing portal is is built and
functional it R reduce the need for the
Manpower in our licensing and
administration we're not there yet so
those temporary positions are are still
uh contemplated to be to be funded um to
have funds available to continue to
compensate them so the positions that
are currently Frozen is um are listed on
page
six I believe that five of those are in
the 89 or excuse me five of those are
full-time positions the none of the 89
that are funded in the budget are
currently filled there are no there are
no vacancies in the budget as presented
okay and you said you're working on a
new portal is there funds for that in
here somewhere no that uh the funds for
that I was working with two separate
contractors but that is a doit
maintained contract and it's arpa funds
so um it they will use them until they
run up it's essentially paid for yes I'm
not confident we're going to be able to
complete it with those funds but we will
not be requesting additional funds for
that gotcha other questions
representative wer
thank you Mr chairman on page
163 uh source of funds education trust
fund a million and a half what is that
money
for I don't think that is our office
anymore I think we end in the middle of
63 where the total number of positions
with 89 I think that's the end of our
office oh wrong okay thank you you have
me panicked representative I could use a
million and a half dollars though I will
say yeah yeah that's the end of section
one right section one General government
right so that's the grand total for all
that stuff thank
you but you can kind of see just as long
as we're on that page right the big
increase in section
one by 519
for million for this year and 645 for
the next one yeah right I mean that's a
huge
increase and section one is all our
section right so it's our stuff going
on so obviously we haven't found the the
big numbers yet yes as you noticed ours
are down we both years yeah right yours
is down yeah so you're not the problem
thank you for saying that we don't think
so either
yes we're we're looking for all right
yes represent mon hey can I ask one one
more question um I should have asked
this when you came in the first time but
um how do the number of lenses that that
you're responsible for compare to other
states you know may like on a per capita
basis or something I mean I guess what
I'm getting at is do we do we license
more than other states or less I don't
know the answer to that I have um we
have a member of our staff who's done
some market analysis for a few other
things that we could we could definitely
have her look into that and and see what
it looks like my back of the napkin math
um of percentage of the population is a
little bit off because uh the 1 uh 3
million is going up right the population
is increasing so I do think it's 15 to
17% of the population though currently
in um would would out hold a license a
credential from this office okay and and
and if I may another yes go and you know
last year there was uh or last session
there was a lot of U shall we say
discussion about um changing
classifications and restructuring and
Licensing and all that stuff
um does that have a significant impact
on your expenditures if if changes like
that get made yeah I I guess what I'll
say kind of conceptually is the the way
that our office incurs costs is either
that uh
members of the state actually or even
out of state get a credential required
by law or they break the law that
governs their profession so uh I'm not
out there telling people hey don't
become a plumber because it costs me
money to give you a license um that you
know so I think
the and I I think the F the reason that
you would have the the office is fee
funded is to say that we want it to be
almost a one for one the amount of of
money that it takes to administer the
licensing would come for those fees and
and no more and really no less so that
that is the goal is to get it to that
place if we have fewer licenses will
have less Revenue but will'll also have
less work you the breaking the law part
is it's kind of implied right you have
to obey by your the laws and rules of
your profession so those enforcement
costs are incurred when people are not
doing what they're supposed to be doing
again if there's fewer license types
then you're not dealing with unlicensed
practice for those professions so the
the cost incurred by giving people
license or doing that enforcement the
the theory is that it's offset with the
fee uh that has not been in balance for
for a number of reasons and um there's
some analysis there's obviously a lot of
tension in budgeting and we haven't
gotten 100% to where I'd like to be
where where that is actually even that
the the scale is balanced but to say
that we're we're able to maintain
operations um I'd love to get it to a
place where it is it's more specific to
the individual boards um but currently
we're kind of looking at a big picture
for the whole office a full reset is
um a a future dream of mine yeah
representative evil so just um on page
five of your presentation um where
you're talking about the changes to hb2
could you just kind of go through those
AB for us and and and so for people that
have hb2 that it starts on page
71 thank you very much um happy to
report is many fewer Pages than the last
bium that deal with
oplc so um there really two big pieces
here um and both related to inspections
so when we were looking at um you know
every agency has had to take a hard look
at their budget and just say what what
do we need um I I can't even say it's
lwh hanging fruit but assessing where
can efficiencies be made what does that
look like and in assessing those
essential functions one of the things
that we looked at is okay so we've got
to get licenses out the door and we have
to make sure that there's timely review
of complaints we're working on that
process I've spoken publicly and in many
other committees about needing to
continue to improve that process to be
more responsive for constituents and
also for lenses who have have complaints
that can be out there for any number of
years and when we looked at inspections
and that kind of compliance piece of it
we were trying to assess what does this
look like what's the public health and
safety protection um there and what is a
licensing function when we were looking
at the mechanic so that's um plumbers
and gas Fitters the mechan it can be a
little bit confusing so plumbers and gas
Fitters um and then um heating service
technicians are within that profession
and then the electrical inspectors those
positions moved from the Department of
Safety in
20121 per legislation over to oplc with
the licensing board now what what has
happened is I think as I was just having
conversation on another uh Bill and
we're also dealing with a similar
situation with assessors is that there's
there's some policy making and some
standard setting and then there's
licensing and sometimes those um pieces
are intertwined in a given um department
and then when the licensing function is
sought to move over to oplc to kind of
just standardize that and and fit it in
and find some efficiencies some of those
policy Pieces come with it that really
are better suited to be in other spaces
um so when we were looking at the
mechanical and electrical inspectors the
the duty of the fire Marshall's office
in terms of regulations involving
um safety um fire concerns code
enforcement of those types of things the
that's really the what these inspectors
are doing they're assisting
municipalities um they're providing a a
critical Public Safety function um but
the positions had traveled with the
board to oplc so the assessment was made
to say this is really a a this is a
safety function uh the fire Marshall's
office is um is utilizing them um as
needed because they have this expertise
they are lienes in the field and so
that's the governor's office um proposed
restoring those based on a policy
consideration not just on I think
initially the conversation was the fees
from this board licensing fees are
paying these inspectors let's put the
inspectors where the fees are uh for a
number of reasons the collective
bargaining salary increases all of those
things expenses have gone up the
licensing fees are not coming close to
covering those costs anymore and the
assessment was this really is a public
safety function so rather than just
making a financial decision I think it
was to make a policy decision to have
them there really where it fits in the
scope of that um office the fire
Marshall's office and the need
there um happy to pause just if there's
any questions but that was the
consideration on that
piece
yes no so I I believe the proposal would
be safety is would be funding that with
General
funds
yep yes and then the second one is uh
related to cosmetology inspections so
the when we were looking at um things
that require Manpower are do we need to
one of the questions I I asked and we
were talking through is do do we need to
be in every Cosmetology shop every year
um doing these inspections a lot of the
concerns are with sanitation procedures
and that type of um just type of concern
the general health and safety um The
Proposal in hb2 is to go um OSHA already
offers a course but it could be an
additional or similar course of a
lifetime certification in the sanitation
procedure specific to barbering and
cosmetology and so to say uh similar to
a f a food service establishment that
has to have you know Serve Safe CER IED
we we don't have state government with
inspectors that are going to restaurants
every year annually just to ensure that
they're they're compliant so the this
provides an option to either a a shop
could be inspected again annually um so
it would be upon initial
application a routine inspection in the
second year and then a renewal and then
a routine in that the subsequent year or
they could um
demonstrate that they've they've
completed this course uh for a lifetime
certification and then that would exempt
them from the need for those inspections
um it does it reduces costs so a a
routine any inspection is is a $100 so
instead of $100 a year this one course
would be a lifetime piece um if shops
choose the the lifetime course in
sanitation we're still providing that
they um the potential is there that we
would need fewer staff on if we we're
not getting to all I think there are
about 3,000 shops and we have three
members of the staff so it would reduce
the workload and the hope would be then
that we would be able to do initial
inspections for on for new shops that
are opening to make sure that they
they're in compliance with all the rules
and then in response to complaints we
would still have an um an inspector on
staff if there's a concern if a compl a
Consumer complaint comes in we could go
do a spot inspection and and and ensure
that there's compliance there deal with
any issues assist with investigation and
bring that before the board so those are
the two considerations
there present R thank you Mr chair so
you said it was $100 an inspection so
the the shop would pay that is that is
that part of their annual uh license fee
it is not part of the licensing fee it's
a separate inspection fee okay so if
someone from your office goes to inspect
a shop they get a $100 bill they like oh
we're inspecting you and that'll cost
you $100 I mean it's it is scheduled in
advance oh okay uh so yes but yes when
when they go out and so again it's
initial so opening a shop if you're
renewing it based on the two years and
then what we would call a um I just lost
the word I said it two minutes ago a
routine inspection on that off year
right so not the renewal year okay um
followup Mr chair so but you were saying
now they could opt to have a uh a a you
know a forever certification if they
take this course how much does that
course cost $59 $59 so it's actually
cost effective for them to take the
course rather than having to renew that
license thank you certainly I I don't
know why you would pick the $200
option uh some may though but we yes so
then that in turn would provide cost
saving to the shop owner but then it
also could potentially um we would need
fewer staff if many shops were choosing
that the option to demonstrate that yeah
I just wanted to say the language she's
talking about is on page 75 I think of
hb2 so you can see the whole process
there thank you we don't have I know
this isn't your area but did you say
restaurants aren't even inspected
annually I I I don't have anything to do
with the restaurants but I guess I was
thinking where I eat my food where I eat
my food I would say has fewer routine
inspections by the state than where you
get your haircut and I thought you know
I think public health and safety could
still be guaranteed with a similar level
of safety protocol again knowing that we
have staff if there is a concern a
concern any consumer can file a
complaint and then we could look into it
I think restaurants are handled by local
um health and factors
okay all right well thank you very much
director thank you happy to correspond
via email with anything else that comes
up all right we will all right let's go
to we have here the board of tax and
land appeals which
is on page
153 and by the way Melissa when we
looking at the grand total for section
one the whole difference is in other
funds so is
that um maybe the transfer of of money
from um rooms and meals to
municipalities got put into the budget
that wasn't before or something like
that so
yeah so yes so I I did want to note the
change
um let me just look at make sure I just
want to verify the fund is
correct for that municipality
distribution that's actually general
fund so that's actually
um y That's agency income so that would
be the big gap in other funds so in 24
fiscal year 24 the municipal
distribution in the treasury budget um
which is on page
141 was budgeted on book for fiscal year
2425 it was budgeted off book because
there was a dedicated Municipal Revenue
fund that was created
in 26 and 27 the treasurer put it back
on the books so there's options because
it is a dedicated fund now and it wasn't
prior that it could be removed and put
it back off books because it is the
dedicated fund or you could leave it on
books but that is the big difference
because if you look on that page in
fiscal year 24 it's 131 million in
fiscal year 25 it's zero right and then
in fiscal year 26 it's
39.7 in 27 it's 145. 6 so that is a big
a big change and a big discrepancy when
you're looking at those total um General
government
lines
okay yeah yep so it was there dedicated
Municipal fund was created went off
books because of that dedicated fund and
then the treasure put it back on the
books I believe she just does that every
year here but you could move it off
because it is a dedicated fund now and
it never was a dedicated fund before
we'll have to ask them when they get
here about why are they adding four
positions on page 141 all right anyways
back to the Bureau of tax and land
appeals Mr chairman just before we go
too much further do you want oplc to
come back as
just I for my notes for Janet to whether
they need to be rescheduled or not oh I
see I don't see a reason at this time
anybody else no yeah they're they're not
General funds right so check them off at
least temporarily yeah all right back to
these guys so we are on page
153 okay welcome all right good
afternoon chairman and members of the
committee it is a pleasure to be here
today my name is Eric wind I am a member
of the board of tax and land appeals um
chair LeBrun wanted to be here today but
was feeling ill today so I will do my
best to fill her shoes and I am joined
today by the board's executive director
and stac um so we are Distributing a
letter I can would be happy to do a
brief overview of what the board is um
what we do and what we have presented
for you today so the board is an
independent agency we hear cases from
various State entities including appeals
from municipalities the Department of
Revenue Administration takings from
either the Department of Transportation
or
municipalities and other tasks including
even in approving BFA Pilots um so at
our core we go back a long ways we have
a lot of history we are a combination of
kind of three board functions a board of
tax review a Board of Equalization
and the imminent domain commission um
and as that has evolved through history
we wound up being called the board of
tax and land
appeals um we are a less formal venue to
hear tax and imminent domain appeals um
and play a key statutory role in looking
at
reassessments um and ensuring
proportionality and reasonable taxation
in furtherance of our
constitution um this is especially
important right now at as what you all
know property values are
skyrocketing um changing dynamically and
governments including local governments
are having a hard time meeting all of
their funding needs so therefore intense
and economic pressures are being placed
on both business owners and
homeowners um so that is the core of
what we do
um the intent is always to provide in a
fair and impartial lowcost
administrative appeal appeal process as
you will see in the materials that we've
presented we've um identified a few
legislative mandates that we would like
to either eliminate or tweak in order to
bring efficiencies in but other than
that the budget we are asking your
favorable consideration of is one that
maintains our current approved Staffing
levels um and then maintains a baseline
of of
expenses so for Staffing we have
proposed and um do you want to touch on
the Staffing one
or um I'll I'll do it at a high level
and then um Miss delat can get into more
details but we have had a difficult time
filling a statutory role of a tax review
appraiser that position is presently
vacant we want to keep that position um
but we have struggled to fill it because
appraisers are in high demand they're
going out and either working in private
Industries or for municipalities for
more more money than we can offer so
what our proposal is is to remove the
statutory requirement that it be an
appraiser and just have it be a position
that is a technical staff
position but which is at the discretion
of the board to fill with any um more
broadly um are appraisers licensed yes
they
are okay just for the benefit of the
division this is on hb2 page 42 I think
the stat statut
changes yes the statutory changes
proposed are in the trailer
bill um we propose one change to the
imminent domain procedure act which is
also already pending before um as House
Bill
268 but the intent here is that we have
a requirement in statute to hold
imminent domain just compensation
hearings in the county where the taking
is occurring um the statute says to hold
it in the respective County Courthouse
or other space as deemed suitable um we
cannot get cour houses to reliably give
us space as far as hearing rooms so we
just want to be able to use our hearing
room in conquered in Johnson Hall um and
remove that requirement that will reduce
State travel expenses at least in theory
will reduce expense those expenses to
some degree um and will reduce the
amount of time that we are spending as
as far as our technical as far as our
clerical staff is spending trying to
find rooms out in the counties um and
then lastly we are prepared to discuss
our filing fees um but I think I will
just open it up for questions all right
so let's start with on page
153 so in 2024 were you m is this the
the missing um tax appraiser is that why
the salaries are lower
line 10 the class line
10 uh
yes Mr chair that is exactly that
position has was vacant in the last bium
um after very many unsuccessful attempts
to post and fill it an interview we
cannot compete um municipalities and
they're paying 20 30 40,000 over what we
could pay we then went to personnel and
worked with then um assistant
commissioner Joe bushard he had found a
very old statute that we ended up going
to GNC we moov some money into a class
102 a contract class to try to contract
for services well unbeknownst to us that
list is also small um of people that
were willing to do contracts and of
course there's the timing of our appeals
with the cases and um so we ended up the
contracts that didn't work out either so
then we're back to person Personnel
working with director rudus uh who has
been ever so helpful and patient and her
team and um they said we'd love to
reclassify this for you to take out the
license requirement to be able to get
the high level technical skills and
analytics that we need however not
require that license and she said but I
cannot do that until we take it out of
the you have to get it out of the law
and then that gives us the greater
flexibility and what I can tell you I
have been
when I started in 2002 we had we were an
agency of 12 we are at an agency of six
I have two staff and this vacant
position um
losing this
position it it just we cannot function
we need we need help um we have
definitely not asked for a 7D in many
years we used to have two tax review
appraisers and and some years ago I
don't know 2011 maybe we we said you
could take one out of the law so they
did and then we had it filled with one
and we were functioning and it was fine
um but the reality is and I I will quote
the Governor from yesterday I heard her
say property taxes are a burden for many
gr Staters we hear that I hear that I
talks to your taxpayers every day day in
and day out and I tell you it is it's
it's really getting to the point where
we are the people that listen and we
offer them the opportunity to be heard
and what we're seeing more and more of
right now is there's an up uptick and
reassessments and what's happening is in
the reassessment field you have people
that it's an aging profession people are
aging out they're
retiring they might some of them might
come back and and contract with a couple
of companies for part-time work but
that's going to be shortlived the
reality is when I call do and folks over
there in the RightWay division they're
telling me they can't even get
appraisers and they're Contracting with
an outstate firm just to do and if you
read the union leader this morning that
was on the front
page uh that I had never heard of and
they appraiser list I asked for it for
purposes of Contracting and they said
well we'll give it to you but don't
bother because most of them are
retiring that's great but we still need
those services so we're going to try to
repur we're hoping to be if we can the
position to be able to reclassify it to
do more investigating data collection
doing analysis on spreadsheets our
reassessment cases
um there we have all heard that the
commercial properties are not
appreciating like the
residential um you have some towns that
cannot we have um and I I will use the
town of colbrook as a prime example C
Brook cannot find an assessor they they
cannot find a
contractor no one wants to go up and
work up
there they're now exploring a TR toown
approach where maybe like what we have
over on the other side of the state
where New London Sunapee and Newber I
was going to say the tri towns um that
works well for you guys colbrook is
trying to do something with other towns
to get an assessor so you either have
people you know if you're if you're down
in in Manchester and nashille they have
in in-house accessor they're paid very
well um then you have contractors you
have some local companies and you have
some out of state companies out ofate
companies do things you know maybe a
little bit differently too so there's a
blend but we're there the board is there
to make sure when those revals and those
studies get done and they don't
something seems out of
skew we need the technical skills to be
able to Paw through 23,000 sales and
figure out what
happened when you take a city like naswa
who had I don't know it's over 60,000
sales one year that's a lot and and we
just we need that but we need to we have
to be creative with How We Do It um so
uh that is our hope to keep the position
otherwise we are 90% General funded we
are not net positive our filing fees we
could never be self-funded um we are 10%
Highway funds that is for the work that
number does percentage does fluctuate
when I was first here in 2002 it was 20%
it's based on how many appeals of
emminent domain are filed and um we're
picking up back with the widening of 93
we we widen it widened up to uh exit
exit 3 anyways and now we're we're
starting to do the new 4 a ramp um so
we're seeing more takings this appraiser
position we would use on imminent domain
as well um and that was also very
helpful for that so we are seeing an
uptick in cases our case load Is Us
usually um roughly we gave you a chart
um just to show you over the last 10
years yeah let me ask about that chart
yep so this is a
360 350 or so cases per year are these
cases filed or cases where the full
board made a decision these are filed by
taxpayers these are filed okay um
because my understanding is that in a
lot of
cases um they're they're settled on the
on the courthouse steps sort of right I
mean that before you get to a full
hearing and decision the parties settle
frequently is that right or is that
wrong we've always had um roughly on
average of 68% we've held pretty firm on
that 68% settlement rate the cases were
left to here are the ones that need to
be heard they're either issues of first
impression um might have an interesting
legal issue when it comes to exemptions
or the like that's definitely what we
hear um otherwise we've had some comp
licated appraisal issues we have had
Hydro El electric facilities and I can
tell you that was we have had 12 weeks
at a time of different versions of
electric and and generation facility
cases we have two weeks coming up in
March for hydros again those are
complicated those take time um and we're
having what the board does is when the
appeal is filed um our goal is to
process that within a year meaning by
the time you get there till decision and
final resolution it's it's about a year
the court takes longer than that but
again we're hearing from from scratch
this isn't a record review this is a
full evidentiary they're allowed to
bring in evidence and Witnesses and
trial you know it it is like we have
because we have the same jurisdiction
with the Superior Court um we run it
very much the same in that way um but
the complicated cases the cases the
hundred about that they hear a year
they hear roughly 100 um cases are not
necessarily resolved in one year some
take multiple years reassessments could
go on for three or four years because
they're that complicated I always have a
rolling open case list of 7 to 800
appeals depending on the given year when
nashor or Manchester does a reval yeah
it's a busy year um but there's a
constant we are our filing deadlines in
September so there's a constant rolling
docket the docket never goes to zero but
the cases they heard are roughly 100 a
year and they have always been the ones
that absolutely needed it okay so and I
understand the $65 filing fee hasn't
been changed in 50 years is that right
um well last time we we chatted um we
sent over some data on that and it's let
me give me there one second um couple of
things I can offer you we attempted to
change that in 2009 with House Bill 47 6
at the time and that was in the 2009
session with Representatives at the time
uh Betsy Patton and oh another person I
jack but I can't think of his last name
um parts of the bill there were 12
places in law where IT addresses our
filing fee and all of those did not
change um but parts of the bill we were
trying to change the Quorum and a couple
of other things um because at the time
emminent domain part of the 90% of the
filing if he went back into the highway
fund that is no longer the case so that
we tried to get that changed in 2009 it
did not go anywhere last time when we
met last bium um we gave an explanation
of how the filing fees sort of work and
let me grab
that and I'm happy to provide that if
you want I brought copies of what we
submitted last time to to um address
that but basically the filing fees were
um because we as Eric stated we were a
Tax Commission back prior to the 50s um
the filing fees were based on how many
how many um owners uh then it went to a
$40 fee in 1992 it was changed to 65
that is where it sits today Emin and
domain has been $100 um at least since
we merged with the eminent domain
Commission in 1983 so 65 and 92 that's
where we're at we recommended $1100 um
and in the last session when we were
here two years ago we recommended maybe
uh looking at assessments um over you
know maybe drawing a line and saying
anything over
$750,000 of valuation could be one fee
and anything less than that could be
something different um the board has its
authority to wave its fees they do that
frequently with the elderly low and
moderate um and that will always
continue so
my point is
um how much is in dispute on the 100
cases that you're
deciding well again because the chart at
the back of the letter shows you the
almost 70 areas of jurisdiction that we
have they're not all necessarily
valuation sometimes with especially with
exemp ition it's it's about what's
income what's not income um so I
can I I would really I don't even know
if we could get that out of a database
to get you the data but we see
properties in all ranges we had one the
other day what was that one it was like
less than
200,000 what was we had a we had a
60,000 um very recently so yeah is
that's the value of the property the
value of the property so the amount of
tax on this property
is 1,800 or something like that okay
you're spending $10,000 a case on
average to process these cases you have
a 100 cases and you're spending a
million dollars right so it makes no
sense to spend
$10,000 on a case that where where 2,000
is in
dispute sure I appreciate where you're
coming from I believe that the board's
position is that we are supposed to be a
lowcost alternative to the courts I I'm
not sure what the court would tell you
for their cost per case if you were to
do the math the way that you've done it
but whether you're appealing a $60,000
property or millions of dollars in
utility company assets which we also
heard this last year um then you know
doing an average like that I'm not sure
what is your biggest
case in the last year the utility
company assets out of Milton might have
been the biggest case and I'm not
remembering the exact figure but I can
tell you last time we provided data we
had Granite Ridge versus londonairy 470
million okay that was
20 trying to I don't have a year uh
2022 tax year um and just to further
clarify on our Form B when we submitted
the budget um our we estimate our
current Baseline of appeals cost to
process is
$232 our Target in 20 fiscal 27 would be
roughly over 2400 um when we do the math
but that's only when you count 300 cases
not the actual 100 that
are that are being
decided oh sure it's it's the average
it's actually based on 400 an average of
400 filed yeah because even though they
don't get to hearing they can still be
processed in in a que doing other
procedures we don't just go to file to
hearing we have other things that get
done and that could take up to nine
months before they get to hearing so
there is still processing of these
matters regardless if they settle at the
11th Hour um okay yes and just like in
Superior Court they are entitled to
Discovery um and we have in property tax
appeals a mediation requirement because
it is State policy to encourage
settlement of adjudicated
matters now when you have a $400 million
case what is how much is in dispute is
it one side saying it should be 390 and
the other one says it should be 410 or
is it 400 versus 200 or something like
that what is
the I think it can vary pretty
significantly yeah I sometimes I've seen
commercial properties where you know
there they could be arguing over it
could be a million dollar difference it
could be $220,000 difference it depends
on the
appraisers which witness is more
credible and and which methodology of
how they got to their value is the board
finds is the most credible way to Value
the property it really does depend but
there is always money on the table with
the commercial properties for sure okay
can you get us more like a a chart that
shows in in the r in ranges you know we
had we had 20 cases that were up to
100,000 we had you know another 10 cases
that were up to 200,000 and so on you
know yes half a million to a million a
million to 5 million you know whatever
yeah I think that's exactly what we did
last time and I'm happy to re-update
exactly what we sent um we broke it down
into four ranges going from 250,000 to a
million and Granite Ridge was 470 that
was an outlier obviously I'm not sure
what the hydros are are valued at but
all right represent do
that yeah you you went from a air fairly
low low volume Court to one that's
become very
controversial the uh oap
decision uh about not being allowed tax
exemption just by being a charitable
organization was seized by some
assessing company went around all the
towns in my area saying we can make you
a lot of money by getting rid of these
tax exemptions they came to my town they
got rid of 24 tax
exemptions just on the strength of that
decision which is not a court of law and
now I'm fighting this battle for my
organization which wasn't tax exempt
because of being a charal organization
but because of an exchange they made
with the town which the idiots in the
town didn't bother to Reas the reason
why we had a tax exemption they just
said oh you your a charitable
organization would taken away and they
sent letter us to 24 organizations with
very little research on why we had tax
exemption fighting it now but this
is this got way out of hand where's the
appeal from this decision and especially
this company that's running around
saying oh we'll make you a lot more
taxes it's it's just wrong that suddenly
blanket all 24 organizations that were
tax Exempted get letters say and you're
not including
churches veterans organizations all
sorts of things so this this got way out
of hand and ESP especially when it
wasn't a court of law so where is the
appeal for this
decision well I'm I'm absolutely happy
to have that conversation and explain
what happened um in that case and uh I
know when the board released that we had
several conversations with the Senate
back a couple years ago when that
happened and um once sort of um I don't
know if you've read the decision but I'm
happy to discuss that okay okay well
where um the board at at that point um
again was the exemption laws chapter 72
in particular is one of the most
difficult tax laws that I've personally
ever read it's very um in need of
overhaul and I have been we've been
trying to work with some Representatives
on that to bring a bill forward to try
to streamline the process um but this
was about entities getting charitable
exemptions without following the
statutory
requirements always filed every
year1 never they claim because
they all right uh representative G yeah
thank you um the letter that you you
presented to us says that the board has
four key areas of jurisdiction
and does that chat include all those
four areas or not yes thank you yeah it
comes out to about 2400 bucks a
case yeah well the case filed but not
necessarily case finished anyways
representative evil and then
representative rung and then we're going
to have to move on okay just just a
couple of things I I think the whole
concept of your uh group is that you
provide a lower cost alternative to
people that are trying to appeal tax
decisions rather than going to the
courts so even though we're talking
about the costs it still would be a lot
less than what it would be in the court
and you have to give people some sort of
recourse right and to the person that
has $60,000 home and is's questioning
1,800 that's still a lot of money to
them so that's just a comment did you
say that you you had a hand out there
that had fee in
information um I do it's two years old
but I'm happy to provide it I I don't
know I wouldn't mind seeing it I think
it's interesting just discuss the fee
issue seeing as they haven't been um
raised since whatever you said
1992 um yeah and then the other thing I
wanted to ask you just in the context of
what the chairman just said the the what
is the uh opportunity to appeal from the
tax appeals board to Superior Court or
what's the or is it turn cut off or
what's the process no the appeal from a
board decision in three of the four
areas is to the Supreme Court Supreme
cour um in imminent domain matters then
they can appeal to the superior court
for a denovo trial there so there would
be two bites at the Apple before going
to the Supreme Court in the imminent
domain um procedure okay so their
opportunity is not cut off at the
correct
thank you and if it would be helpful um
I was in anticipation of talking about
fees I can talk a little bit about fees
and other states and neighboring states
if that would be useful information does
anyone do fees sliding scale based on
the amount of dispute yes Massachusetts
I believe does sliding scale starting at
$65 and going all the way up to $500
depending on the value
appealed yeah still a tiny amount of
money anyways go ahead represent
have two questions one is there uh if
someone's disputing their
assessment how many of those cases May
settle at the municipal level do you
have before they even have to go to you
it seems as we can solve more problems
at you know within that municipality to
spare some of the disputes that reach
you so we do not actually have
jurisdiction unless they have disputed
their assessment at the municipal level
and gone through a process there so in
order to even reach us they need to have
disputed the assessed value at the
municipal level okay so you would expect
that if
municipalities had a
thorough you know maybe some appeals
process or recourse at the municipal
level do anticipate it might reduce the
number of cases that come to
you I think it would vary based on the
thoroughness of the review at the
municipal level um sometimes there are
multiple levels of review when there's
been a reassessment where they have an
opportunity for an informal hearing
before even filing for an abatement um
but I think the generally speaking I
think the more thorough the process at
the municipal level the more they can
weed out the cases that are easy to weed
out um without them being appealed to
the state or the to either the board or
the or the court okay and then uh just
one question what are the qualifications
for someone to be an
assessor you know that um assessors are
are certified um under there's a Dr
rules that cover that what they have to
go to there's classes obviously training
they have to come to a board hearing
there's they have to have mass appraisal
background I don't know off the top of
my head uh it's been a long time since
I've looked at those I know there
there's some rumor that ASB might be
working on tweaking some of those and
making it maybe um I don't want to use
the word easier but maybe changing some
of those um but I'm honestly I it's it
is a certification and there are
absolute criteria and quality buried in
some one of those rules that talks about
those what what is required UMC overseas
that um yeah it might be now I I'm not
sure exactly how yeah that might have
changed too I was just thinking of ways
we can encourage more people to go into
that field yeah I've heard people going
to high school fairs believe it or not
trying to promote it as a career because
it's not known so okay thank you all
right so we have to move on to the
housing appeals
board um thank you for coming and we may
talk again so let's see they are on page
hi Rogers the
chairman yeah my name is David Rogers
I'm the chairman of the housing appeals
board and with me today is our Clerk and
administrator uh Elizabeth Berard um we
are here to um provide some information
about our our budget I will start off by
saying that we are in agreement with
um almost every as aspect of of the
governor's proposed budget and and the
riter um we provide a alternative um
hearing process to the Superior Court in
cases of appeals largely from local U
Municipal zoning boards of adjustment
and planning boards um we provide a
three- member board uh one attorney
which is myself and then there are two
other members with uh extensive
backgrounds and experience in both
engineering and planning so we provide a
level of expertise that may not be
available at the superior court level
which is the uh companion alternative
appeal process for litigants um we have
also um a level of experience that um a
judge at the suprior court level may not
have and we are not um redirected or or
given other um tasks to complete which a
superior court judge May encounter in
the in the course of their work um we
are also last chair become a superior
court judge or was that he was not the
chair but yes Michael class is now a
superior court judge and I understand
he's been there just about a year uh
I've been on board as chairman uh with
the board since March of last year so
I'm a relative newcomer and this is my
first time before you folks so okay
please bear with me but um I'm glad to
be here and to uh so some judges have
experience right excuse me some judges
have this experience yes and he does
when he's not hearing criminal cases or
other yeah right other competing factors
um so we we have a uh a well- comprised
board um Miss manard has been with the
board since its Inception several years
ago and is uh my go-to person when it
comes to All Things uh logistical and
historical great institutional knowledge
and invaluable to our board um we
provide um a speedier um hearing process
and decision- making proc process our
appeals are taken to the Supreme Court
and in the course of the existence of
this board uh there have been
approximately a dozen appeals to the
Supreme Court only been overturned twice
so that's a fairly decent track record
uh even though I have very little of
anything to do with that personally um
we are
um it's a seasonal board in a sense um a
lot of Planning and Zoning Board
hearings at the local level are held
more during the building and
construction seasons in spring summer
and fall so uh we have received thus far
this year four appeals um but we
anticipate receiving significantly more
as time goes by we also provide a a a
lower cost alternative for litigants to
come before us and and file their
appeals from various zoning and planning
boards we also do not uh and we are not
uh we are directed by Statute to not
substitute our judgment for that of the
local boards I know uh just what I
recall reading about the creation of the
housing appeals board was that there was
some concern that it would become a
state level decision maker as opposed to
a local level one and that has we are
adamant about avoiding that appearance
and and taking that route we do not do
that at all we simply review what
happened at the lower level determine if
it's reasonable and lawful if it is we
will generally affirm what happened if
not we send it back for them to re uh
more or less where we're at financially
uh in terms of the budget um we have we
were able to reduce the four or meet the
4% guideline uh from last fall and we
are prepared to move forward with the
budget as addressed by the governor in
her budget writer thank you so how many
cases per year and what fees are
collected uh the fee is 250 250 the
filing fee is $250 that's a an
all-inclusive fee uh that doesn't cover
attorneys representing parties or
anything like that but our fee is 250
and we on average we get somewhere in
the neighborhood of 25 cases per year um
correction I'm sorry sorry over 30 30
closer to about 33 cases per year 33
cases I'm sorry um so
it again we're we're we try to be as
efficient as we can with these and hear
them promptly and and render decisions
in a prompt way um given the makeup of
the board over the last year there was
um
a couple of openings on the board for a
period of time that disrupted things a
little bit but we have now gotten back
on track quite well and are moving
forward efficiently do you have any
appraisal
experience
um I could tell you what a baseball
cards worth maybe but uh that's that's
about it okay representative Ms uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you for uh joining
us today um do do you have any sense at
all as to how much those
33 uh individuals
filing cases with you or claims with you
are saving by going through the appeals
the housing appeals process versus going
to
court I I would have to do some research
on that I don't have a figure off the
top of my head i' I've been an attorney
in New Hampshire since 1988 so I have
been in private practice and uh have
worked for the state since 2005 is a
hearing officer in various uh agencies
um I know when my first appointment was
in 1993 by Governor merell to the
workers compensation appeals board and I
know that was created as similarly as an
alternative to the court system um not
only as a financial um savings but it's
a time uh and efficiency savings it was
years before they were getting hearings
on workers comp cases and they created
the board and it was reduced to months
and uh it was quite a an improvement
that board exists to today
um so to answer your question
representative I would I would say that
there's a significant enough savings I
mean many of the litigants have
attorneys the towns obviously have
lawyers representing them and then I
would guess it's upwards of probably 80%
75 to 80% of the um appellants or the
applicants have lawyers representing
them um but again the the length of the
proceedings the amount of um discovery
that goes on again we're a review board
so unlike the BT La that you just heard
from we don't have evidentiary hearings
we don't have witnesses we don't have um
testimony uh there isn't Discovery and
that sort of thing that drives up
litigation costs typically so um I would
venture to say that it is a a more cost
effective and time effective manner of
of appealing a local decision if I could
follow um oh go ahead if I may piggy
back off of that on average it takes
about five and a half months from the
date that a an appeal is filed with our
board to when a final decision is is
rendered so that's a significant cost
savings and legal fees I would say
compared to probably going through the
Superior Court where your appeal could
take I don't know maybe a year or two to
conclusion you may have five and a half
months go by without even seeing a
courtroom and I assume in your case
there's very few
settlements is that right we what we've
seen occa there are occasional
settlements that's accurate generally
speaking often when we get a hearing we
remand it then there will be a
settlement at that point because they
don't want to necessarily come back or
at least they have a sense of what a
third party adjudicator would do and
they can look at their case a little
more objectively
usually so there are some okay
representative Ms followup yeah no I
guess where I was going is that you know
if you've got if you got 33 cases a year
and your annual budget is about you know
$550,000 you know that's that's about 15
to $20,000 per case um and presumably
that would be that I I guess I'm trying
to get a handle is that the kind of
expense that that all parties involved
in a in a in a proceeding would would
would typically
spend I would think it could approach
that in in in total you know between a
municipality and a yeah and I think it's
important to look at both parties I
didn't mean just the cost attorney fees
and drawn out nature of these things and
again the uh the length of time I I
think that's one of the biggest savings
it gives people the
decision more rapidly than it would if
it were limited to the Superior Court
representative
werk Mr chairman what sort of decisions
are you making versus what the uh tax
and land appeals looks at what's what's
the nature of the of the dispute yeah um
again we were hearing uh appeals of
zoning board cases which are things like
variances special exceptions at the
local level um planning board cases of
of um you know building um development
and and things of that sort so we we
site plan work we don't get into the tax
aspects of it I mean that may come up as
a tangential thing but we don't uh
that's not our focus by any means it's
it's more whether or not the local board
has done what they are responsible for
doing and that varies from town to Town
the municipalities have different
ordinances so we have to look
individually at each case and determine
if they follow their rules and if they
have then generally as I said we will
uphold what happened below if they
haven't we'll send back some level of
instruction and try to get them to
follow their own rules better and and
municipalities are often uh I've had 12
years of experience on zoning and local
zoning and planning boards in three
different towns and uh I found that
there are personalities um to say the
least um that's frequently an
interesting and a healthy thing and it
brings different perspectives to the to
the table but sometimes those
personalities get in the way of making a
decision that is necessarily proper
under the ordinance so certainly
sometimes in some of these cases the
records are quite voluminous yeah I mean
they can span projects can span multiple
years and the certified records can be
hundreds of pages long and sometimes our
decisions are five to six pages and
sometimes our decisions are anywhere
from 12 to 13 we we had a hearing just
yesterday that has nearly a thousand
pages of of record that came up up to us
that we now have to review so it it's a
it can be a timec consuming process
that's not to say every single page is
relevant and important it's the other
one but we have to review that in order
to determine that so so that's the bulk
of your time it's not really sitting
with the attorneys that might be a day
or something the actual hearings
themselves are relatively short they
they're like appeals before The Supreme
Court you know you have an a lot of time
um we'll have a representative from the
town speaking the appellant which may be
the person who had initially applied for
a variance let's say or it may be an
abutter in which case you'll probably
have three parties the abutter the
property owner in the town um and we
allow time for all those people to be
heard but frequently we're reviewing the
record and that's the time consuming
part of it so when we get to a hearing
ideally we're familiar enough with the
case having read through this stack of
documents that we can ask intelligent
questions if necessary of the parties
when they're before us and that's
largely what we do and then we go away
and we deliberate among the three of us
as to how we want to proceed with this
and and come to a conclusion as a board
now sometimes there are it could be a
two to one decision it could be a
dissenting opinion at times I haven't
experienced that personally yet but I
know that's a possibility and I've had
other boards that did that uh but it's
kind of remarkable how um you can kind
of come to a consensus and again remand
is a an effective tool to educate local
loal zoning and planning boards as to
what our take on their zoning ordinance
is and hopefully get a better result at
the local level before they even reach
us so at the present you don't have any
unfilled positions all four positions
are full that's right okay and and um
you're getting more computer work it
looks like transfers to
oit yeah um up let Elizabeth explain
that but um she was very instrumental in
getting us a software program called
Legal files which is used among other
agencies in the state and it's designed
to be a case management and operation
software program we are also um adding
some hard new hardware not a lot um but
we hold our hearings uh in a hearing
room that is equipped with WebEx and it
broadcasts not only locally but um
anybody can log in and the public can
see it the hearings are open to the
public um so we're trying to improve the
quality of that broadcast as well
okay uh yes representative evil thank
you Mr chair I have just a couple of
questions um so it's a threers board
correct okay and then unfortunately I
don't have the RSA in front of me but
the RSA was very specific about the
requirements for the board members to
make sure that there are no conflicts
have you been able to find people to sit
on the board in compliance with the
statute we fortunately have
uh in fact one of the line items in our
budget is for temporary board members
who are um appointed uh by the Supreme
Court um we submit their name and
request that they be seated in cases
where there are uh conflicts of interest
among board members permanent board
members and we'll have a temporary
member who will then stay with that case
from outset to uh conclusion um and
fortunately we've been able to get um
whether it be a land surveyor
professional engineer planning person
and we've been able to do that because
that's one thing that I've heard about
the board is that there have been some
issues well there were largely what
happened and I'll just try to address it
briefly um last just about a year ago
when um Michael class was elevated to a
Judicial position in the Superior Court
the former chairman also resigned around
the same time so there were at 1.2
openings and suprem Court went through
interviews I was part of that process
was um a appointed by the governor and
um nominated and appointed by the
governor in March of last year a a third
member Stephanie bile was appointed in
April so we've had a full board since
then I will say there's a bit of a
learning curve there's a a getting up to
speed with the procedures and the all
the the various regulations and things
that go along with it but as I mentioned
earlier we are in a very good position
right now compared to where we were just
a year ago and that's you know I guess
partly my fault because I'm a warm body
who's shown up at the hearings but um we
have a complete board and for the most
part our board has been intact but we do
address conflicts of interest and we
take those very seriously recusal is not
something that we are um you know we
refuse to do just because we are have a
pride factor involved there yeah as just
as I say under the RSA there were
certain requirements for the people that
were hired so that was part of my in
addition to just the issue of recusal
just the question of whether those
qualifications were met but as I say I
don't have the RSA in front of me so I
just um had the question the other thing
is do you have any sense at all of how
many people are seeking the housing
appeals board venue for their um appeals
of local decisions as opposed to just
going to the superior court I I don't
personally have statistics on that I
would suspect I mean if I were advising
a client who was an appeal they wanted
to raise I would probably recommend the
housing appeals board just because it's
more expeditious and and
efficient you want to oh simly to your
question representative RSA 6798 governs
temporary board member appointment and
you are correct um so the person who's
appointed in place of a permanent board
member has to have the same
qualifications for that board member who
recused
themselves and we do have an A a list of
a dozen or so people people that we call
on uh attorneys uh Professional
Engineers land surveyors we've been very
fortunate in
that yep so is there a fair amount of
money for Consultants or something like
that in the budget
or if you if you got all these side
people um I'm sorry representative are
are you referencing perhaps our um class
50 personal service temporary appointees
yeah that's not much money there
um I don't see
consult we've been fortunate I would say
in that um the number of times board
members have had to recuse themselves uh
has been Limited in the past with of
course the of the uh exception where we
lost two of our board members right
around the same time last year so I
think that this is a a fair estimate for
um necessary funds to cover our
temporary board
members and um to that effect RSA 798
also governs compensation for temporary
board members and they are paid on a per
DM rate at75 whopping dollars a
day I
think I'm glad you think
that oh
okay yeah I guess I was on the
wrong all right all right other
questions no no okay
thank you very much thank you for your
time um probably not but I'm not ready
to accept
this goad could we have a little I mean
most of the folks that come in here and
talk to us they present they have
something that has some statistical
information on if we could just have a
little more information about your the
number of cases you have and that sort
of happy to prepare that would that
would be really helpful rather than
we're just operating sort of in a vacuum
as a lawyer I was hoping you would ask
because I I loveing I'm a lawyer too so
there you go so I write it in leg and
you'll understand it that's good right
um and and just as far as my question
about the um qualifications of the board
members and that that would be help
thank you and is it an outcome
necessarily for the town for the
applicant or is there sometimes you know
split the baby kind of thing
um I guess splitting the baby is what a
remand would do and and we have a choice
with remands we can vacate and remand
meaning we wipe out the entire decision
and say start all over again or we um
reverse and say well it's not really
right but you know try again and we're
getting to a point where we're trying to
be a little more direct in instructing a
zoning Board of where we feel they their
shortcomings were or a planning board
that is up to them to you know
incorporate into their decisions and um
their rehearing process um but yeah
we're trying to do some education in
fact U few weeks ago we met during the
employee meet and greet with governor
aot and we mentioned we said we were all
there all four of us and she was very um
encouraged by our presence and the
board's role and what she thought would
be important of us educating local
municipalities as to the zoning board
and um housing or uh planning board
process where that would encourage
development more at the local level we
don't take a as I say a direct role in
telling towns exactly what to do but we
can give them some education and
directive as to how we analyze things
and review things and then hopefully
they can address that at the local level
okay so when you give us a table make it
there's a column which is
outcome for the town for the applicant
for remand yeah with IAL remand without
or whatever however you want to do it we
will certainly sit down and do that for
you yes thank you okay all right so
we're going to recess until uh 245 and
the executive
Council
e
e e
158 and
we'll isn't that on
158 15
y there it is it says executive Council
kind of the middle of the page there
yeah all right let's
welcome executive
counselor good afternoon my name is
Megan Rose I'm the executive assistant
for the office of the executive
Council and
so what do you
do everything everything
okay so I provide um administrative
assistance to all of the executive
counselors and um in when it comes to
their roles as employees of the state
like we don't have anything that's
myself and one part-time person in the
office and we have nothing to do with
the political aspect of their of their
job but just the state aspect of their
job so we we do the budget we do office
purchasing we help with any of their
paperwork or needs that they have in the
office that have to do with State stuff
we help with the meetings things of that
nature um I provided for you all today
and yesterday uh before my appearance
here today just a presentation of our
office that kind of explains what the
makeup of our office is which literally
is the five exe executive counselors
they're all elected and then my position
as the full-time executive assistant and
then we have a part-time office
assistant um can you explain um do you
have this page 158 I do yeah can you
explain there's there's three lines is
is the part-timer the line 16 is that
yes hold on and I can tell you exactly
in my notes what so let's see class
class 16 is the part-time office
assistant budget gotcha class so the
class 11 is the annual salary uh budget
line for the executive counselors right
um Class 12 is my annual salary right
and then there's class 20 is our office
expenses and class 70 is the stipend the
counselors get in in lie of a travel
voucher and mileage
okay and and do counselors get benefits
too um they do not
they're no they do not get benefits it's
one of those things where they could but
they would have to pay the full amount
themselves I
see okay good did you get married is
that why your benefits went up so much
um no the um kids I have I have kids and
um congrat something had happened and I
lost and no no all grown so something
had happened and um they ended up one of
them got removed and I was like well
that's not going to work so I had to put
them all back on because it'll be a
while before they reach 26 gotcha okay
all right any
questions I don't see any no I don't
think there's much we can do with this
one
yeah yeah yeah why don't you how often
is the redistricting the redistricting
is every 10 years years um in accord or
in conjunction with the
census so the map you have in there is
our most recent all right I'll recognize
representative eil for a motion thank
you Mr chairman um I'd like to uh move
that we approve the budget of the
executive Council as presented I'll
second it okay any
discussion all right should we show of
hands all right you
congratulations thank you so much all
right so we're going to come back
at uh 3:15 for right to know
utsman okay wait we're really getting
into the weeds
here welcome to division
one right to know um but I didn't even
know such a person
existed it's 170,000 a year geez
well oh I didn't
remember how quickly they
forget
e
e e
right to know udman Assuming he's here
and there he is
okay
yeah thank you thank you sir so please
introduce yourself well I am Thomas FC
of the office of the right to know
Ombudsman also known as the RKO as a
matter of fact I'm the entirety of the
ABC uh known as the RKO which
is that too uh which is relatively new
and busy office for a new agent anyway
uh thank you for having me here today
and maybe I'll have the simplest but one
of the most perplexing agency budget
presentations that you've had uh I first
staff the office in uh on January 27
2023 it's presently set by law to expire
on July 1 2025 unless renewed funded and
staffed By Me Or Another appointee prior
to that date that being the case the
budget under consideration is for a
period when the agency might or might
not exist there's currently a bill in
house house bill 111 which if it's
passed would extend the life of the
agency for 2 years uh that came out of
house Judiciary uh autop pass with
Amendment uh I know the committee's had
a busy day so I will actually be be
brief and turn the page did the did the
amendment change the uh it didn't change
the extension of the agency for two
years it uh addressed um some of the
things that I could do it uh I believe
that it said that it would not have the
authority to uh award attorney's fees it
also specified that people that appear
before me who are not attorneys aren't
subject
to uh problems for the unauthorized
practice of law those two things were
added great right thank you so uh I'm a
quasi judicial agency existing in the ex
itive Branch charged by the legislature
with resolving disputes between a member
of the public and a governmental or a
public body or public agency regarding
disputes that arise under RSA 91a which
is the right to no law I won't describe
all that that entails but I brought with
me copies of my office's first annual
report which actually covers activities
from when the agency began until
December 31st
2024 as of this morning you can also
find that online
the portions of the report that briefly
relate to agency budgetary matters are
at Pages 84 and
35 as to the budget that's been proposed
I appear at Pages 125 and 126 the
governor's recommended operating budget
the primary expenses of my office are my
salary and benefits Uh current expenses
requested for the bium that you're
looking at now are $3,000
$4,000 uh that's primarily for postage
and miscellaneous office
supplies I now have my own
administrative rules my website but it's
been my experience that the nature and
the functions of my office are sometimes
misunderstood and uh it I spend a good
deal of time addressing email and
walk-in inquiries which poses something
of a difficulty for a one-man neutral
decision maker one of the things that
was raised in the course of public
comments during my Ru making with uh my
agency Ru making
is that it would be generally helpful to
produce something like a user's guide
explaining what my office does how it
functions and its processes
administrative rules are out there but
administrative rules have to be written
a particular way and uh sometimes people
find it a little daunting to get through
so the suggestion was that I create a
users's guide in this budget uh there is
a request uh for funds to retain an
independent contractor a legal intern to
assist in the creation of a user's guide
and potentially Aid in some other
operations the office such as answering
a lot of inquiries that I
Reed there you'll see that there is $1
allocated for personnel uh for Personnel
Services and that's so that there's a
line for potentially a part-time
employee should it ever be determined
that the state budget could absorb that
ideally the office if the office is
continue is to continue into the future
It ultimately likely needs at least one
other person in capable of Performing
all of my functions on at least
part-time basis bis and I say that
because I'm a oneman neutral decision
maker if I have a conflict on a case I
have to recuse myself from that case
there's nobody else that can pick it up
uh there might need to be a statutory
Amendment if there's if that's to occur
at some point um because it says that
the Ombudsman makes decisions so this is
a full-time job right why would you have
a conflict it it's it's a little more
than the fulltime job yes but why would
you have a conflict in that case uh if
if something happens in the case I don't
believe that I can address it fairly I
have to recuse myself if I was involved
with one of the parties I would have to
recuse myself financially involved
primarily Oh you mean like your brother
had a case a real conflict of interests
and I I did I had one case in which I
did not believe that I could judge a
case fairly based on the things that
happened in the case and I had to accuse
myself and the question then is what
happens I said well new agency I guess
we're going to find out because I have
to accuse myself if I I'm subject to a
lot of codes of conduct as an attorney
and uh I if I'm off I'm off so that's
one of the things and and another
individual would also be able to assist
in things like getting out basic notices
things like that uh but I did not put
that in uh as a request here because I
understand that this is a budget that is
focusing on reduction rather than
expansion
um so but ideally that that and an
administrative assistant would probably
be of great use to my agency or to me
personally which is basically the same
thing
um well I just wish the I wanted the
committee to be aware of that um so what
I'm requesting here is uh consultant
expenses for basically the users guide
some additional assistance and some of
the other some of the other things that
I haven't been able to get around to
maybe an intern maybe that help get
people a little bit more informed about
what I do maybe spread the word about
the
agency uh you'll see that in my in my
budget there's no allocation for things
like office expense uh I'm office space
expense that's because my agency is
administratively attached to Department
of State uh I operate independently of
them but uh they have assigned me space
which I would assume is absorbed in
their budget as opposed to my budget and
right now I'm in uh room 12 of the State
House Annex down the basement uh this
budget assumes that uh my relationship
with the secretary of state will
continue in that way so that's why I
don't see that in
there as to
reductions uh I have from the beginning
I have sincerely attempted to keep my
offices expenditures to the bare minimum
required in order to perform the job um
in order to really attempt to identify
the agency's most basic
needs um from the time officer's first
staff till December 21st 2024
miscellaneous expenditures other than
postage amounted to under
$5,000 uh with the caveat the Department
of State has been picking up office
space and so
forth at this point I don't believe that
the proposed budget is uh reasonably
capable of uh much further reduction
without eliminating me
entirely uh couple of new items are
found in there request are $500 in
instate travel all my hearings in 2023
and 2024 have been held in conquered
sometimes to the annoyance of some of
the participants uh last month I did
travel for a hearing on the road and uh
I'm considering doing that again in the
future if it's warranted in a particular
case and at present uh the travel that I
would do for the agency is at my
personal
expense uh for equipment I'm hoping to
get uh a a lockbox uh for the filing of
in-person uh fees for filing a case my
fees are $25 that's
statutory um and also for filing of uh
pleadings and so forth right now people
walk in and hand things to me or I or
the door which remains
unlocked folks come in and put stuff on
my desk so I'm hoping to get things like
that perhaps a backup uh recording
device right now I'm using a a uh
cassette tape recorder for my home um
and with the tapes paid for by the state
and that's one of the expenses but the
recorder itself is is mine okay um you
said fees are $25 how many cases a year
roughly uh since I have started well
let's see I could tell you that had I
divide my stuff into two categories
inquiries which is people contacting me
about anything it could be I want to
file this I want to do that I want to
know how you work it could be a press
inquiry it could be a right to no
request itself I've had 282 of those
since I started of those
282 as of today I believe it's 78 filed
cases so the 282 don't pay the $25 fee
that's no no no they don't okay the $25
fee just comes from the file cases which
so that's that's 78 cases over 23 months
since whatever January 27 2023 to now
is gotcha all right I guess that's
that's even two
years yeah so it's slightly more than
two years 24 months slightly I started I
started the middle of a budget cycle so
this is actually the first round of
budgets in which I've had input now on
these cases do you always give a
decision or do they sometimes settle oh
uh a good number one of the things RSA
541 a38 is uh provides that uh it's
really the policy of the state to
encourage informal disposition of cases
and I try to I try to encourage that and
I I state right out that I encourage
that usually if that occurs it occurs at
a prehearing conference or after
prehearing conference uh most cases end
up at a prehearing conference not all
cases but many uh the other thing that I
found is that uh the offices mere
existence may help to resolve cases and
by that I mean I've had I've had people
for example that just see see me
something they're sending to a
governmental unit and uh that way they
know that something might happen unless
they can resolve it so yeah I I I'm not
sure what the exact number is about the
number that resolve themselves and the
number that resolve with my input but
it's a fair amount okay half maybe here
something I I really don't want to make
a guess okay fine
um
so
um how long I guess how how complicated
are these cases how much time does it
take you to uh to deal with one I have
to say that that really depends on the
case and the parties involved the
quickest anything has been in and out
has been eight days I still have some
cases from
2023 and it all depends on the cases and
what happens in them there you know any
case you can file motions of different
types motions to compel motions for me
to do an in- camera review as a matter
of fact my first case which came in
almost immediately was to do an in
camera review in that case in camera
review means that I view I I take a look
at something that's been withheld
and make a determination about whether
it should be released the um the first
case that I had was 700 pages of
redacted material that I had to sit down
and go through and figure out whether or
not each redaction was proper on the
other hand there are some requests for
uh for uh in camera review that it's
just a page and that's
fast sometimes it takes
months so does the governmental agency
that the person is having the dispute
with always give you the DAT the
information that the person wants or not
necessarily not necessarily it really
depends in the case um sometimes people
are just complaining about the and this
is probably the most common complaint is
that there's not a timely response and
for that those cases can get resolved
pretty easily without me just by saying
that you might come talk to me because
the 5-day business day response period
for doing one of the three things that's
an absolute and uh those cases I don't
see anything those are just inquiries
you mean no no those could be cases and
say look uh someone is it's been over
five days and I've gotten
nothing well that case is probably not
one of my difficult
cases okay um so my last question is um
C Can you estimate how many of the cases
the 78 cases you've had would have gone
to court had you not been here I don't
know yeah I I really don't know I mean I
imagine that some of the cases that
are I'm not sure if somebody would say
look it's been a month and I haven't
heard anything I'm going to spend the
amount of cost to go to court whereas
they might say that they'll spend the
$25 in order me but I couldn't really
make that estimation I got you all right
thank you representative
MZ thank you Mr chair thank you for uh
for coming in um after you've made a
ruling what what do you what do you have
in the way of enforcement
mechanisms well my ruling to be appeal
to the Superior Court
um I have the law that says you're
supposed to listen to me and if you I
don't have a sheriff's apartment I don't
have you know I don't have contemp
Powers I do have a power that says I can
make a negative inference if someone
fails to abide by things that I
order but that's a negative inference on
paper so uh ultimately I I have found
that sometimes people say I want you to
order a witness to come in
my statute doesn't say that I like a
court that I have jurisdiction over that
person I don't have penina power to go
tell somebody from the outside to come
in and sit in my office and I'm going to
go get you if you don't um
so I've
got the strength of my
personality um have have you have in in
your two years doing this job have you
taken anyone to court for I I don't no I
I issue my ruling I don't know how many
of my cases have been appealed I'm not
advised if a cases appealed so I don't
know I I don't I don't have a question I
just wanted to say I looked at the
calendar
hb11 is on the regular calendar for
tomorrow and it's recommended otpa by a
pretty large
margin anything else I can answer to you
answer I'm
happy um and I don't know if this Falls
within your purview or not but I mean
one of the things that that I've heard
quite a bit of uh
from our particularly our local school
boards is the voluminous amounts of uh
request for information that they're
getting um do you have you gotten
involved in that at all I mean in terms
of uh any cases um and and I'm I'm I
would imagine that some that somebody
who's asking for the information might
come to you and say hey they're not
giving it to to you but do you ever do
you get the school board coming to you
and saying this is unreasonable that's
interesting the way my statute is
written a complaint can be filed by a
party AG grieved by a violation of 91a
that means that the governmental unit
can't bring a case to me can't the only
one that can is a person that's grieved
by a violation of 91a and those are the
those are that's the governmental unit
so I've never had a case any any
governmental unit attempt to bring a
case to me I assume because they've read
the statute and they say it looks like
claimants can bring them but I can't now
in the course of a case of course the
governmental unit could say look this is
just unjust vexatious and I want uh
sanctions against that person I've had
that come up on a number of
occasions representative
Le thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
appearing today so I was just going
through your report which is I found
pretty interesting that um most of the
claimants that says here prosay without
another representative and then below
that I guess seven claimants appeared
through an attorney so these are people
primarily just coming in because they've
got a complaint generally against the
municipality is a rule or one of the
difficulties I have is a lot of uh right
to no requests
don't they stem from something else
sometimes there's some kind of dispute
underlying dispute and the claimant
might come in and say well I want this
because I have to explain that I can't
resolve the underlying dispute only the
91a aspect of it I'm not sure if that
gets to your question but no it's a good
report though there's a lot to it so
you've obviously done a little work look
a little busier than maybe some of the
other boards you're by
yourself a lot I'm easy to
find so back to this question of of
voluminous requests so we've heard that
um sometimes people
there's no exception in 91a for the
volume of stuff right but but the the uh
agency is able to charge the cost of
producing whatever it is is just the
cost the actual cost the actual copying
costs not the
labor I see not looking it up or
whatever is that what you mean it's just
the cost so you might find uh you might
find charges of 25 cents 10 cents a
dollar but it has to be cost based
without the labor okay so even if it's
to produce 5,000 Pages or something like
that right I mean there's been some
adjustments recently to 91a that that
address that uh about particularly about
emails and what what you can charge for
that that's a recent Amendment 91 I hav
had had an opportunity to have a case on
anything like that yet uh and you know
91a gets changed a lot and when people
people often say that's what that's
going what's that going to do to your
office I have no control over that I
it's what it does to people on the
outside and if there's a dispute that's
based on the amendment so I don't know
change 91a and see what happens and as
an unclassified employee you have a
contract right or not no it's a I'm an
unclassified employee which is I'm a
labor grade GG on uh the unclassified
system uh it's I see so you're basically
salary you're at will so if it ends no
I'm not at will I'm uh appointed to a
term which expires on July 1st 2025
unless I get reappointed which I might
or might not we don't know and I may or
may not have an agency but until that
time I am that is my job and not at will
gotcha all right thank you
representative
um I if you if you don't mind just humor
me with this you know this line of uh
thought that I was going on um is are
there are there are there situations in
other states where the the role that an
equivalent to you would be playing where
they would be looking at you know kind
of what I would call Bo both sides of
the information request I mean what what
I heard you say is that basically it's
one-sided it's it's it's the the the
individual wants information from the
government the government's not getting
it they have the right to appeal but if
they go to the government and that the
government thinks it's excessive the
government has no right to appe well
they can in they can say in their case
that my defense to what you have brought
is that this is unreasonable unjust
vexatious they can make that as a
defense but but they can't they can't
bring a case are there other states
where that is permitted is or is that
just not the way law certain if there
are other states that do that when I
when I first started one of the things I
did is I looked around to other people
who had a position like this and the
first thing that I found out is that
well there's a couple of different ways
of doing things there's the kind of the
model that we have which is called an
ombudsman but actually he a quasi
judicial official and then there's other
states that have an ombudsman which is
somebody that actually goes out and
tries is more of an advocate but not
really an advocate they try to assist
the side they're they're they provide
more guidance to the people I have to
kind of remove myself from it and just
look at it neutrally and say okay that
or that and I think I talked to Maine
and I think that Maine's the one that
point it out to me that this is more
quasi judicial than a lot of states and
sometimes that's confusing because the
title of the job and I can understand
how someone would be confused by the
title of the job and also when you look
at the definitions of what I do what I
do I'm not like one of my first one of
my frequent first inquiries was was
whether I was the DHHS utsman in order
to resolve their disputes with you know
people involved in medical things I'm
not that's on my voicemail
now I have to say a lot there because in
my when people call because I've got a
lot of ethical constraints I can't
really have a one-sided contact with one
party I have to remove myself a bit
which is hard to do when you're the guy
that also has to be responsive to
inquiries like the guy that has to be
probably more responsive than
most so do you have any sort of evidence
that the creation of your office has
improved compliance with 91a I don't
know
um I I guess I'm trying to think of what
I would use as a as a metric for
that well I guess the metric I would use
is that um I've driven myself out of
business and I haven't done that yet
okay how about number of 91a cases filed
in court yeah I'm I know the court has
that information but I don't have it
okay Melissa we can ask for that yeah
all right thank you all right other
questions from the
committee all right i' I'm Ren dry so
thank you very much you
care we have about five minutes and then
we
have no not and then we have uh Public
Employee Labor
Relations oh yeah
I don't think
so
e
e e
45 shall we
welcome let's
see you
are public employees Labor Relations
Board please introduce yourself good
afternoon my name is Doug ingersol I'm
the uh executive director of the Public
Employee Relations Board I've been with
the board uh since 2006 the board itself
was established in 1975 so it's coming
up on uh 50 its 50th
Anniversary uh the jurisdiction of the
board relates to the uh administration
of the state's Collective public sector
collective bargaining law uh and that's
applicable to public employees and
public
employers at the State County uh City
and Municipal level uh as you know
legislative employees are not eligible
to form pargeting units
um and the work of the board is uh
carried out by a nine member board uh
three members with experience in
management three members with experience
in labor and three who serve as chairs
and represent the public interest and
whenever the board acts uh it acts with
a quorum with one from each of those
categories and the chairs typically are
attorneys who have uh at least some
experience in litigation because uh when
the board has to hear contested cases
that knowledge and skill set um becomes
very
important uh in addition to the board
members there are four uh authorized
classified employee positions three of
those are filled current
one is vacant uh I'm in one of those
positions I also have a hearing officer
staff attorney and then I have one uh
support staff
person um in terms of activity level and
some of this is covered in the handout
uh we have averaged about 106 case
filings over the past five
years and those are in uh categories
um such as bargaining unit petitions
challenge election petitions uh
modification petitions unfair Labor
practice complaints declaratory
rulings uh as well as petitions for the
appointments of grievance arbitrators
and petitions for the appointment of
bargaining impass mediators and
bargaining impass uh fact finders we've
a averaged about 270 decisions in orders
over the past five fiscal years all of
these are posted on the board's website
uh as well as all orders dating back to
uh
1976 we conduct uh as part of our
operations we conduct prehearing
conferences status conferences
pre-election conferences uh as well as
the hearings themselves the hearings are
evidentiary hearings we
function uh like a trial court with a
very specialized area of jurisdiction
and so the normal protocols that you
would find
uh in a regular Court setting are the
same ones that we follow in other words
uh Witnesses are called to present
testimony their the questions posed to
Witnesses are subject to objections
which the board has to resolve and then
the board also receives evidence in the
form of exhibits uh typically after the
close of every hearing there is a period
of time requested by the parties to file
post hearing briefs which is their final
opportunity sum to summarize and argue
their case to the board after that's
done uh a decisional issue either by a
hearing officer if the case Was Heard by
a hearing officer or a decisional issue
by the board if it's a board decision I
sit with the board uh they tell me what
their decision is and I write the
decision the hearing officer writes uh
and I do sometimes sit as a hearing
officer but the hearing officer writes
their own decision all such decisions
whether by the hearing officer or or the
board are subject to an internal review
process if it's a hearing officer
decision there's two levels of review uh
a motion for re a review motion for
review which the board looks at and then
the board's decision on that motion is
subject to a motion for rehearing the
board's decision if they hear the case
uh in the first instance is subject to a
motion for rehearing uh and all of these
motions are the opportunity for the
board to review the decision to consider
arguments about uh the possibility that
there are errors in the written decision
and to address and correct those
including scheduling further proceedings
after that process is complete and the
decision becomes final uh the decisions
are subject to uh a rule 10 appeal to
the state supreme court those are
discretionary appeals but I think since
2010 uh the court has accepted uh almost
every single appeal that's been
filed uh and in terms of
uh other activity at the board uh
the the reason for the board's existence
is so that uh employees can organize
form bargaining units and negotiate
contracts and uh the parties when they
settle a contract are required to file
those with the board uh we maintain an
inventory of those contracts they're
published on our website along with the
list of all bargaining unit
certifications and I have included a
table on page four of the handout uh
with some detail on bargaining units and
current contracts but the the major
takeaway from that is that 93% of the
contracts that we have on file are
current and by that I mean the contracts
have not yet reached their stated
expiration date the 42 that have expired
mostly cons consist of contracts that
expired in 2004 a fair number of those
expired December 31 uh another popular
date uh and this is in the education
setting is June
30th sometimes there's a lag uh in when
successor contracts are negotiated and
approved and when they get filed with
the board so I anticipate over the next
six months we we will receive a fair
number of current successor contracts
for the 42 expired ones uh in our
current inventory historically uh during
my tenure with the board a 93% current
approval uh level is very high uh so the
system seems to be
working uh I think on the say again what
do you mean by 93% approv so of the
contracts listed in that
table 93% of them are current they
haven't reached their stated expiration
date
42 42 of the contracts uh exp have
reached their expiration date uh most of
those expired in 2024 so for example a
contract Oh you mean so certain number
of people are operating without a
contract well they operate under the
status quo Doctrine yeah they continue
to operate under the terms established
under the contracts so and and I'm
suggesting that there actually may be
successor contracts in place that have
not come into yet come into our
office uh what did mean by a
pre-election hearing so uh one category
of cases that we do has to do with
either new bargaining unit formation or
unions challenging another Union to
represent the bargaining unit and in
there are preliminary proceedings to
First determine a bargaining unit if
necessary sometimes they're agreed upon
uh and if a case is approved for
election because we have to hold an
election to determine who if anybody is
going to represent the bargaining unit
we use the pre-election conference which
is a a meeting involving the union and
the public employer and my staff to
decide when the election's going to be
where it's going to be uh how long the
polling is going to be whether it's
going to be on site or mail ballot okay
representative Ms thank you Mr chair
thank you for coming in
um uh what is the what is the the the
the overlap or or boundaries of respons
responsibilities between you and the NL
nlrb there is there is no overlap the
National Labor Relations Board is
responsible for collective bargaining
for private sector
employees public sector collective
bargaining is determined by the
states
so but it's a similar function I guess
is that it's similar but I the
infrastructure and the way the National
Labor Rel Relations Board operates is
very different than the way most of at
least most of this the boards like ours
in New England function gotcha
representative R thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um I'm
assuming under Municipal as far as the
employer type that that includes school
districts yeah
so right and that's also true for the
cities so it's the it's it would include
school districts it includes law
enforcement includes firefighter
bargaining units um there are actually
uh about
305 education contracts on file with us
some of those cover teachers some of
them cover par professionals some of
them cover administrative staff some of
them cover people who work in custodial
type positions but I those are not
broken out in this
table I'm not seeing any money in this
page for the board are they paid or not
well there is that's one of the things I
wanted to get to but the board received
uh per DM and if you turn to the last
page I included a couple of notes and
note five um addresses this topic when
the statute and the board was created in
1975 the per DM per day was $25 it was
increased to
$50 uh in the mid1 1980s I believe in
1985 has it hasn't changed since then so
for 40 years the PDM has been
$50 uh this year I have included uh a
request to increase that perdum to
$250 which I think I believe is
consistent with the change from 1975 to
1985 as well as other economic
considerations uh so for the class 50
expense uh if if I was working up a line
based on a $50 per DM I would have put
2,000 in that line I put
10,000 uh and I have also requested an
amendment to the applicable statute
which is referenced in form E I believe
so on the governor's budget request they
left they included the
$10,000 uh but if my understanding of
the trailer bill is correct uh that's
where the governor would include any
necessary statutory amendments uh to
implement no we have the 10,000 in our
budget so
it it's it's in the it's in the budget
request correct no but it's in the
budget House Bill one okay it but
there it's a statutory it's a statutory
fee oh I see yeah 273 A2 Roman numeral 7
needs to be amended to change the number
from 50 to 250 I and that's not in House
Bill 2 yet is that what you're saying
it's not reflected in the Governor's
trailer Bill based on my reading of that
okay so so Melissa you or Jack you make
sure that yes and I know I submitted
several
forms in the fall and early
winter on this topic I believe to the
appropriate people so I don't know if it
was a conscious decision or oversight
yeah Melissa if you do have that
language if you could send that to me
that would be great representative
Grille yes so I was wondering how many
times a year does board meet so the the
the board physically will come into the
office uh to hear an unfair Labor
practice charge uh all the other cases
are normally heard by a hearing officer
uh my goal if I'm doing my job correctly
is to prevent that from happening as
much as possible so some years they're
in the office more than others but
usually 10 uh cases or less a year but
they also uh deliberate on uh
motions for review of hearing officer
decisions on a fairly regular basis they
don't come into the office to do that we
do that uh using a video conferencing
feature but that would count as a
working on a case like that would count
as a day uh but you have to keep in mind
when they get a case like that they're
getting the entire record of the
proceedings all the
pleadings uh all the exhibits as well as
the decision and then the motion for
review and the objection so they have to
spend time before they deliberate to to
uh understand what the issues are so
they can make an informed decision
obviously I'm not able to police that
but uh I always staff those
deliberations and I'm always very
impressed by the U attentiveness that
the board pays to these kinds of of
motions they take their uh duties very
seriously if it's $250 a day that's only
40 Man days for
$110,000 right so and you need three at
a time right I think we're distinguished
from some of the other boards for
example the board of tax and land
appeals I think has full-time board
members in our case uh the primary
responsibility for making sure that the
operations of the plrb are running
correctly and smoothly is falls on me
uh okay I see another hand yes
representating people I just thank you
for coming I just wondered if you had
trouble getting people to to serve on
the board no uh we currently have uh
only two vacant positions uh we have two
chairs two management and three labor
right now so I haven't been actively
recruiting not that I recruit but my my
normal strategy and I did go through
this 10 12 years ago is to talk to the
other board members and who do you know
who do you know uh and Chuck Temple had
come on board in 2010 or 11 and he had
made some suggestions of people he had
come on as a chair and made some
suggestions for some other board members
and we were able to get a couple other
chairs to come on um and then Chuck
subsequently went on to the superior
court and one of the individuals he
suggested David Burns came on and then
he left to and he was put on on the
court but since then uh there our chairs
have been pretty stable availability is
a big issue uh that's why we have
multiple board members but if we give
them enough advanced notice uh they're
usually because they're most most of
them are working they're usually able to
find Space on their calendar but they
are are never happy if there's a last
minute settlement when they're blocked
out time are they appointed by the
governor yes Governor nominates
executive Council
confirms
and I I assume these are there's no fees
for these cases there's a uh $60 fee
associated with the unfair Labor
practice complaint and that's it oh okay
I think the idea is we want to encourage
both sides to use the board as a
resource and not create any kind of
financial
obstacle and has that been in a place
for 50 years since the since the
beginning
yeah okay um but the other cases are
just as significant right or even more
so yes right yeah they have to do more
with the administration and management
of a bargaining unit once it's up and
running but there are no filing fees
associated with that so I don't know why
the unfair Labor practice was singled
out for a filing fee maybe in 1975 $60
was cost prohibitive and and protected
against uh frequent
filing has the number of cases stayed
pretty constant over the years it
fluctuates but the numbers on average
and I have tracked since at least
2010 uh the numbers tend to stay pretty
constant I mean you'll see years where
you get quite a few unfair labor
practices and you wonder what's going on
uh and then other times it'll things
will quiet down but you'll see a surge
in other types of cases got any other
questions represent LE just quickly
again the average number of cases a year
that your board handles 106 are the
filings over the last the average over
the last five fiscal
years of months I just Googled um
inflation since
1975 and a $60 fee in 1975 would be
worth
$352
today yeah that makes more sense I think
but anyway all
right so
all right well it's it's something
anyways all right um any other questions
no all
right no we'll wait on this one thank
you thank you thank you all right so
we're coming back Friday I believe at
10: oh no one one right because there's
fiscal yes okay I'll beone you'll be
gone okay really get to sleep yeah
tomorrow we have a house session and
tomorrow house session usual usual time
yeah I'll watch you next week okay
good
T make sure I keep them